bonjour et bienvenue pour ce quatrième
cours de paléo mammalogie ou aujourd'hui
nous allons parler des carnivores mais
aussi des micromammifères alors pourquoi
je fais les micromammifères en même
temps que les carnivores
c'est pour une raison très simple c'est
que quand j'annonce que je vais faire le
cours sur les micromammifères bas
personne ne vient voilà donc maintenant
je les fais avec les carnivores comme ça
vous n'avez pas le choix vous êtes assis
là vous pouvez pas y échapper
donc vous allez manger du
micromammifères mais évidemment c'est un
cours très light sur les micromammifères
pour une raison très simple c'est que
c'est que si je devais faire un cours
complet sur les micromammifères il y en
a tellement à dire que ça prendrait des
plombes donc donc c'est vraiment la
version ultra réduite du d'un cours sur
les micromammifères donc commençons par
les carnivores donc déjà une première
chose intéressante à propos des
carnivores c'est que tous les mammifères
que on appelle le carnivore
appartiennent à un seul clader c'est le
clad des carnivores a donc ça déjà ça
rend les choses beaucoup plus simples à
gérer
donc vous vous rappelez de l'opposition
entre phylogénie moléculaire et
phylogénie morphologiques chez les
mammifères bombe à l'écart niveau rats
ont toujours été tous ensemble ça n'a
jamais été un problème voilà donc pour
une fois qu'il ya un truc qui est simple
en paléo mammalogie on va pas se
plaindre voilà tous les tous les
mammifères carnivores appartiennent tôt
clad carnivore à fann l'histoire du
moins pour du moins si on considère les
espèces modernes parce qu'évidemment
nous avons vu les maisonnées qui dès
qu'ils étaient des ongulés carnivores
mais comme ils ont disparu ce n'est plus
un problème
alors les carnivores et bien ils sont
caractérisés tout simplement par leur
dentition évidemment une dentition avec
deux généralement de grandes canines des
incisives pointu et évidemment des dents
qui sont ces co dont tu c'est à dire
qu'ils forment une lame coupante donc
une dent qui est fait pour couper la
viande
jusque là tout va bien et surtout ce qui
va nous intéresse qui ce qui est
vraiment l'un des caractères signature
des carnivores à c'est la présence du
complexe p4m un donc p4 comme
prémolaires supérieur et m
1 comme molaires inférieur donc p4 en
majuscules et m1 en minuscules au final
pour indiquer que c'est la p4 supérieur
et la m1 inférieur qui forment le
complexe des carnassière donc cesser
carnassière ce sont des dents qui sont
plus grosses que les autres au final et
qui agissent véritablement comme des
ciseaux qui se limitent les unes contre
les autres et qui s'aiguisent de cette
façon et qui agissent comme des ciseaux
qui coupent la viande de façon très
efficace
donc vous avez peut-être déjà vu votre
chien essayé de couper non pas avec ses
canines mais avec ses molaires et bien
c'est parce qu'il met en fait la viande
sous enfin la viande l'os ou quoi qu'il
soit en train de manger il le met sous
son complexe p4m 1 parce que c'est là
qu'il a le plus de puissance aussi toute
la toute l'anatomie du crâne des
carnivores est fait pour que à ce niveau
de l'appareil mastic ateurs se développe
le plus de puissance donc ce complexe p4
est là on va voir que c'est la signature
vraiment des carnivores la signature
dentaire des carnivores ensuite vous
avez des caractères osseux évidemment
sur le crâne
l'un d'entre eux est la réduction du
de l'os lacrymal donc vous voyez ici
toute petite lame osseuse là c'est l'os
lacrymal il est tout petit voire même
complètement absents il y à aussi la
bulletin panique qui est complètement
ossifié chez tous les carnivores et on
va voir que ça a son importance puisque
il va y avoir des divisions au niveau de
la bulletin panique qui vont finalement
permettre de séparer taxonomique mans
certains clad de carnivores donc
retenez bien que la bulle est aussi fier
et si vous êtes vraiment sportif vous
pouvez retenir qu'il y a un os etc
totain panique et 2o en tout 1 panique
qui forment la bulle donc il ya trois os
différent à l'intérieur de la bulle mais
ça à la limite vous n'êtes pas obligé de
le retenir ça puisque ça n'aura pas
d'importance
on peut on peut continuer l'histoire
sans vraiment de retenir ça mais la
bulle aussi fier c'est un caractère
important comme les ongulés n'ont pas de
clavicule et ils vont présenter des
adaptations à à la course
l'une d'entre elles et leurs postures
digi tigre had donc ils ne sont pas
plantigrade
ils ne sont pas on july grade ils sont
dix jti grade c'est à dire qu'il marche
sur les doigts et on a un os une fusion
des ossements du du carp donc entre le
scaphoïde et le lunaire donc le
scaphoïde et le lunaire dans pardon le
scaphoïde à l'extérieur le lunaire à
l'intérieur sont fusionnés et forme anos
dit ce cas faut lunaire donc cet os ce
cas faut lunaire c'est le séparer c'est
si vous trouvez une patte isolé de
carnivores ça vous permet immédiatement
de savoir que cette pâte appartient à un
carnivore il n'y a pas de doute là
dessus
enfin on va évidemment avoir des griffes
et non pas des sabots ou bien des ongles
ça ça paraît assez évident pour un
carnivore et les grippes seront souvent
très fortement développé un autre
caractère intéressant des carnivores
c'est leur cerveau le cerveau des
carnivores est généralement plus
développé que celui des herbivores qui
leur sont contemporains donc là par
exemple vous avez une comparaison entre
les ordres archaïque de carnivores et
les ordres archaïque dont bull et donc
les ongulés en pointillés les carnivores
en ligne en ligne
solide vous avez la taille du cerveau en
quotient dans ses valises à sion donc
corrigé pour la taille du corps et vous
avez le vous avez les fréquences
d'animaux mais c'est pas vraiment
important ce qui est important c'est de
voir que la taille du cerveau en fait
l'écart de taille du cerveau entre les
ongulés c'est à dire les proies et les
carnivores donc les carnivores les
ordres ac archaïque avait déjà un
cerveau plus gros que les ors que les
ongulés archaïque donc les condyles
artres par exemple et puis ensuite vous
regardez les ordres du palais au gène
est pareil les carnivores ont aussi un
cerveau plus gros que les herbivores en
moyenne et aux néogène pareil
les carnivores on t'as plus gros cerveau
et les ordres moderne c'est la même
chose donc
de manière générale les carnivores
évidemment si on se permet de faire un
raccourci entre taille du cerveau et
intelligence les carnivores sont plus
intelligents que leurs proies
mais bon comme je le disais il faut se
permettre ce raccourci entre taille du
cerveau et intelligence ce que tout le
monde n'est pas n'a pas envie de faire
et un autre caractère et un caractère un
peu plus marrant au niveau de
l'évolution des carnivores c'est que
tous les carnivores ont un bac l homme
très très développée donc le bas qu
l'homme c'est l'os pénien l'os qui se
trouve à l'intérieur du pénis et alors
on le retrouve chez plusieurs ordre de
mammifères notamment les rongeurs les
primates les chauves souris mais chez
les carnivores on sait pas trop pourquoi
il est vachement gros il est vachement
développer et là vous pouvez voir donc
le losc baignade un chien par exemple
qui a l'air content de voir son maître
et vous pouvez voir ici le bas qu
l'homme d'un d'un mort ce donc le bas qu
l'homme d'un morse vous pouvez voir qui
est je suis là je fais un bon gros mâle
viril un bon il faut voir aussi que la
photo les perspectives sont un peu
faussés par rapport à la taille du
monsieur qui est un peu en retrait mais
quand même ça fait un beau véhicule
homme quoi et donc elle est l'origine
évolutive de ce bail que l'homme est
encore pas très nets alors la plupart
des biologistes pense qu'il s'agit d'une
année aux formations c'est-à-dire danos
qui s'est formée nouvellement un parent
ossification de tissu qui était
autrefois mou mais les anatomistes et
les paléontologues pense que le bas qu
l'homme en fait une histoire une origine
évolutif beaucoup plus ancienne et
notamment certains la font remonter
jusqu'au 6 novembre c'est à dire
jusqu'au synappci d' non malien en fait
il s'agirait de l'os épi pubiens donc
vous avez ici le voilà le bassin liliom
donc qu'on voit ici le et le pubis qui
se trouve à l'avant de l'isc yom à
l'arrière donc qu'on voit ici la voici
le pubis et à l'avant du pubis vous avez
le pré pubis voilà où hausse
épi public donc rappelez-vous l'os et
puis public c'est aussi ce qu'on appelle
leur slot ce marsupial chez les
marsupiaux ou bien mais on l'appelle et
puis pubis chez les mots notres m et
bien cette hausse et puis public donc il
a donné l' os marsupial chez les
marsupiaux les puis le lépi public
là c'est plus pu bien chez les mots
notres m et chez les mammifères
placentaires chez qui on ne trouve
absolument jamais lot de cépie pubiens
comme par hasard c'est chez eux qu'on
trouve le bas qu l'homme à peu près au
même endroit
donc ça c'est un premier indice que le
bas qu l'homme pourrait être lancée puis
pu bien l'aimer placentaire n'ont jamais
de ces pubiens mais par contre mais par
contre les les animaux qui ont un os
et puis pubiens ou un os marsupial n'ont
jamais de bascule sommes donc ya pas de
chevauchement entre les deux anatomy
donc déjà ça c'est un premier indice
intéressant
ensuite on a il ya un cas particulier
une espèce de rongeurs qui s'appelle
applaudi pia qui vient en amérique du
nord et chez eux le bas qu l'homme a une
paire d'articulation une paire
d'articulation qui donc rappelle pas mal
les articles l'articulation de l'os et
puis pu bien avec le pubis donc sur 7
sur 7 applaudissent ya finalement on
peut voir que le bac que le bas qu
l'homme est le reste d'un os qui
autrefois avait une articulation
probablement avec le bassin et est le
résultat de la fusion de deux eaux
symétrique comme les pies pubis et donc
ça ça point très sain pointerait du
doigt vers justement de l'origine près
pubienne de dubaku l'homme mais c'est
encore évidemment très des fins j'ai
envie de dire que c'est encore très
débattue mais la vérité c'est que les
les biologistes ont tellement inondées
on va dire la littérature avec l'idée
que que le bas qu l'homme était une néo
formation donc un os sorti de nulle part
que finalement cette idée là elle a un
peu été enterrés d'ailleurs vous pouvez
voir que les
illustration que je vous montre à propos
de cette idée là sont sont de facture
bien ancienne voilà mais ça veut pas
dire que l'idée a été validé elle a
vraiment été oubliée il n'y a pas
vraiment d'argument contre cette idée là
au final parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
de débat qui a jamais été engagée à
propos de cette idée là sinon je me
permettrai pas évidemment de vous
montrer une idée qui est obsolète elle
n'est pas obsolète elle a été un peu
ouais elle a été glissé sous le tapis et
et oublié puis bon bah je trouvais
intéressant de la ramener au niveau de
la ramener au niveau des carnivores
puisque le losc vaincu l'homme est si
grand et si développé chez les vaincus
l'homme chez les carnivores et
évidemment comme toute hausse les
fractures ça arrive
est ce que vous voyez devant vous êtes
exactement ce que vous imaginez que
c'est il s'agit d'un bac eu l'homme d'un
loup d'un loup nord-américains le canis
dix russes et vous voyez ici le ce qui
correspond au canal séminal ici donc par
là que part c'est par là que passe la
semence et vous voyez ici une magnifique
fracture qui a été re soudé donc c'est
pas un os qui a été cassé une fois que
l'animal est mort annoncé à 9 ce qui a
été cassé du vivant et ressouder et
comme vous pouvez le voir après il a eu
un peu le lac et kate en coin comme on
dirait et enfin dernière remarque à
propos de l'os bacul l'homme sait que
s'il y a un os bascule sommes
extrêmement développé il faut aussi
s'attendre à ce qu'ils aient aussi un os
clitoris très développée chez les
femelles en parallèle etc et c'est
effectivement le cas donc il ya on sait
pas trop on sait pas trop comment ça se
fait il s'agit probablement il ya
probablement une très forte sélection
sexuelle sur la présence du bas qu
l'homme chez les mâles et ensuite en
fait l'os clitoris qui est donc l'os
l'équivalent du bac eu l'homme chez les
ch et les femelles donc le où on
l'appelle aussi beau bel homme donc le
beau bel homme chez les femelles
il en fait il serait peut-être la juste
part effet secondaire c'est à dire que
comme les mâles et les femelles sont de
la même espèce il
ils se partagent le même bagage
génétique et du coup le bagage génétique
qui donne aux mâles un gros bac eu
l'homme est aussi présent chez les
femelles c'est juste qu'ils s'expriment
moi vu que vu qu'elles ont des des gènes
provenant de chromosomes sexuels
différents mais et du coup et notamment
des hormones par exemple les gènes qui
contrôlent les hormones ne se ne
s'exprime pas de la même façon donc mais
mais quand même je simplement par
incidence on va dire par par effets
secondaires par dommage collatéral on
pourrait aussi dire les femelles se
retrouvent n'empêche avec un os clitoris
assez développée donc un beau bel homme
et alors et alors là il ya de la
prouesse technique c'est un article donc
ce que je gémis en capture d'écran c'est
un article qui a était paru dans une
dans une revue à comité de lecture et
donc dans lequel l'auteur a réussi à
glisser dans le titre le mot clitoris
mais aussi le mot beach et ça c'est beau
là il ya de la grosse prouesse technique
évidemment vous ne pouvez faire ça que
quand vous parlez de des chiennes dans
le sens biologique du terme c'est à dire
de la femelle du chien mais n'empêche
caser le mot clitoris et le mot beach
dans un titre dans le titre d'un article
d'une revue à comité de lecture c'est
c'est juste grandiose mais parlons
sérieusement parlons phylogénie les
carnivores d'où qu'ils viennent alors
les carnivores déjà niveau
phylogénétique il se ils se branchent
parmi les lots razia teria donc il
s'agit d'un groupe de l'eau razia terre
et ils sont le groupe frère des folies
dote les folies d'othe que sont les
pangolins donc carnivores et folie dot
partagent un ancêtre en commun
carnivores et pangolin et alors bon déjà
on peut on peut noter que les carnivores
comme les pangolins se nourrissent tous
deux protéines animales
donc même si dans un cas c'est des
invertébrés dans l'autre cas c'est des
vertébrés
encore que certains car niveau enfin je
veux dire si vous regardez les
mangoustes les
les suricates par exemple je ne crache
pas du tout sûr de la protéine d'origine
invertébrés un évidement il mange des
insectes ils mangent ils mangent des
fourmis aussi des termites
donc voilà donc c'est tout de lui de la
protéine animale quoi donc autant
carnivores qu folie dote d'un régime
basé sur la protéine animale donc un
ancêtre commun qu'ils avaient
probablement ce même très et surtout on
retrouve un peu un caractère particulier
qui s'appelle un thorium aussi fier
alors qu'est ce que c'est que le temps
thorium aussi fier emma le temps thorium
c'est là c'est le c'est un petit voile
de tissu qui sépare le cerveau enfin le
les hémisphères cérébraux du cervelet
donc les emmys les hémisphères cérébraux
et le cervelet sont naturellement
séparés par un petit voile de tissus
mous d'une petite membrane si vous
préférez chez tous les animaux mais chez
les carnivores et les folies dote enfin
les pangolins ce voile est aussi fier
c'est ce que vous voyez sur la
radiographie ici et c'est la crête que
vous voyez ici chez les carnivores donc
là on voit le bord de l'eau si si et
vous pouvez voir cette crête développer
très développée ici sur la section et
qui se prolonge ici qui se prolonge sur
le pétrole est qui et qui va jusqu'en
bas donc là sur cette radio de folie
dote de pangolin ça se voit très très
bien ses parents les hémisphères
cérébraux du cervelet ici donc ça c'est
un caractère très particulier des des
folies dot et des carnivores à et qui
donc donne son nom au clad qu'ils
forment donc le clad que forment les
carnivores et les folies dot s'appelle
les hausse tantôt ria du temps torrione
aussi du temps thorium ossifié voit la
hausse tantôt rien et puis
accessoirement ils n'ont pas de
clavicule non plus les les pangolins
donc est-ce que ce qui est pas forcément
intuitif puisque les équipes menées sont
de très bons
ce sont de très bons fourmilier malgré
la présence de clavicule et même
d'annoncer inter clavicule donc c'est
pas forcément une adaptation nécessaire
au mode de vie fourmilier de perdre la
clavicule donc c'est probablement aussi
une scie napo morphy significative
maintenant cherchons l'origine des
carnivores l'origine lointaine et
paléontologique des carnivores et pour
ça il faut remonter au paléo scène et au
paléo scène est ainsi qu à l'eocène on
avait un groupe dominant de carnivore
qui s'appelle les créaude honte donc qui
vivait en même temps que les maisons
nikki des dons qui se partager le butin
on va dire avec les maisons liquide et
elle est créée aux dons en fait
contrairement au miso nick idée il
ressemble beaucoup aux carnivores
moderne tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
une carnassière alors ils ont une vision
une carnassière mais le problème c'est
que c'est pas la même carnassière que
chez les carnivores moderne donc c'est
très discuté encore savoir s'ils sont
vraiment
reliés aux carnivores ou pas ça fait ça
fait débat d'ailleurs j'ai mis créaude
honte entre guillemets pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'en fait il est même très
fortement probable que ce qu'on appelle
les créneaux dont tu ne forment pas un
groupe monofil éthique donc
et quand je dis pas monofil éthique on
on pourrait même considérer poliphile
éthique pas seulement par affi l'éthique
mais carrément poliphile éthique
vraiment des animaux qui finalement
n'aurait rien à voir ensemble et qu'on
ne devrait pas mettre dans un groupe
mais bon on verra jamais leur gêne
encore une fois donc donc c'est par
défaut qu'on en fait un groupe mono
qu'on les met tous dans le même groupe
les créaude honte donc à l'intérieur de
ce groupe
vous avez plusieurs familles familles
qui elles par contre ont des chances
d'être monofil éthiques
mais les familles entre elles ne sont
peut-être pas relié du tout et peut-être
qu'elles ont évolué justement des
carnassière complètement de façon
complètement indépendante donc là
carnassière d oxygène idée par exemple
c'est la m1 m2 donc m 1 supérieur m2
inférieur au lieu de p4 et main et vous
pouvez bien vous imaginez que c'est
enfin je veux dire c'est pas possible de
transformer une m1 m2 en p4 et main
voilà donc les oxygen idée s'ils sont
reliés aux carnivores d'une façon ou
d'une autre ce n'est que de très très
loin quoi voilà
et ils ont évolué alors qu'anna
carnassière très probablement de façon
convergente vous avez les trèfles et
très célèbre i et nos dons ty et donc
les yellow dont il est con retrouve
partout dans le monde y compris en
france
en france on a de très beaux spécimens
de ye no doubt idées qui nous viennent
des gisements du quercy on a de très
beaux spécimens qui viennent aussi de la
marne de la vallée de la marne
donc dans les dépôts paléocène eocène et
oligocène de ces régions et donc c'est
ye no doubt ideye nos dans le premier
ont un complexe carnassiers qui est
formé par la m2 supérieur et la m3
inférieur mais vous voyez les molaires
quand même laissé la même forme la même
forme de carnassière que chez les
coaches et les carnivores donc la
convergence est vraiment parfaite voilà
mais encore une fois on a du mal à voir
comment une m2 m3 se serait transformé
en p4 m1 quoi il
vraiment passé par par un parent stade
bizarre où il y aurait 4 carnassière au
final donc une m2 m3 et une p4 m1 ou
alors il faudrait passer par un stade où
il ya plus de carnassière ou mais on n'a
pas les fossiles pour ça on n'a pas les
possibles pour ça en plus ils n'ont pas
de fusion ce cas faut lunaire donc ça ça
exclut encore une fois une scie napo
morphy qui nous indiquerait clairement
que que que s'est créé au donne son sont
reliés aux carnivores et un autre
caractère c'est la petite taille de la
boîte crânienne qui les distinguent
définitivement des carnivores moderne
enfin des carnivores à mais les cris ou
dante ça les empêche pas d'avoir une
histoire intéressante qui vaut le coup
d'être d'être contée donc comme j'ai dit
c'était les premiers les premiers
carnivore qui soit possiblement reliés à
nos carnivores moderne et alors ils ont
connu un grand succès évolutif au paléo
scène à l'eocène à l'oligocène et puis
bah encore une fois crise de la faim de
l'oligocène oblige vous avez vous allez
avoir une diminution de leur diversité
pendant le milieu scène et une totale
disparition à une fois arrivés au milieu
du miocène en gros
et donc les formes du miocène sont des
formes finalement des reliques à partir
de à partir de l'oligocène les formes de
dons bull et modernes vont prendre le
pas sur les formes dont bull est
archaïque donc les condyles artres et
une bonne partie des paiements gueulé
comme on l'a vu la semaine dernière et
ces nouveaux carnivores finalement vont
concurrencer les créaude honte donc les
yellow dotted et notamment sur leur
propre terrain quoi et et être et les
battre sinon sinon je parlerai des
carnivores comme d'un groupe relictuelle
mais non de ces les scellés yano
d'autres qui ont qui ont morflé et les
formes en fait les seules les formes qui
vont arriver à survivre au cours du
miocène vont avoir cette tendance du
coup à occuper des niches écologiques
que les carnivores que les carnivores à
n'occupe pas et cette position
écologique ça va être d'être des prêts
date des super prédateur mais par delà
toute la super predatory
family possible quoi ça ils vont ils
vont pousser le vice extrêmement loin
donc notamment en afrique justement où
vous rencontrer mais gistau terium qui
est très connu pour être probablement ce
qui a été le plus grand mammifère
carnivore de tous les temps en
concurrence très très proche avec andrew
arcus le crâne de méphisto terium est un
peu plus petit que le crâne dans douze
arcus mais les proportions du corps si
elles sont les mêmes
évidemment on n'a pas de squelettes
complets magisterium mais si les
proportions du corps sont les mêmes que
celles de yellow dont yann aux dons pour
qui on a des des squelettes complets
alors l'animal a pu peser entre une et
trois tonnes alors que landreau arcus
s'il a des proportions similaires à
mézos knicks il a pesé il y aurait eu du
mal à dépasser les hinton donc donc donc
voilà a priori magisterium en porterait
la part du lion à blague
voilà et après et est récemment on
continue encore de découvrir deux des
billets nos totti des géants donc dans
le milieu seine inférieure du kenya on
vient de découvrir cette année dont je
vous parle on est en 2019
on vient de découvrir simbac ou bois
donc si mme baqouba qui dit qui signifie
purement et simplement le lion géant
voilà et et vous pouvez voir donc ça
c'est le crâne d'un lion adultes et ça
c'est la mâchoire inférieure de simba
coups bas donc ça ça envoie du bois
coincé de la bonne bête c'est de la
bonne bête et une masse estimée à une
tonne et demie ce mignon il ya cette
tendance au gigantisme au cours du
miocène chez lenovo thil et qui est très
probablement dû au fait que c'était à
peu près le seul endroit où ils seraient
pas encore enfin la seule niche
écologique où ils seraient pas
concurrencés par les carnivores
directement hélas ils ont tous disparu
au milieu du miocène ça aurait été
tellement drôle d'avoir des légistes
terium encore aujourd'hui et parmi ces
creo dont il ya une famille qui
s'appelle les miyako idea est alors
cette famille là elle est spéciale elle
est là la même distribution que les
autres creo d'entasser paléocène eocène
principalement dans l'hémisphère nord
d'ailleurs uniquement dans l'hémisphère
nord c'est aussi une différence avec les
autres créosote relayer nos d'autres
idées on les retrouve jusqu'en afrique
est d'ailleurs rappelez vous je vous ai
dit qu'à l'époque où les affres et les
afro terre commencent à évoluer c'est lé
seul carnivores présent en afrique
mais voilà les miyako hideux ils sont
plutôt hémisphère nord ils sont plutôt
petits sont plutôt discrets les fossiles
sont relativement rares généralement et
ce qui nous intéresse vraiment dans le
cas de la discussion sur l'origine des
carnivores c'est que les miyako id ou du
moins les demi à coheed ont un complexe
p4m un donc là carnassière c'est la p4
enfin le complexe carnassiers est le
complexe p4m 1 et chez certaines espèces
on va avoir un os cafo lunaire ya même
chez certaines espèces on va avoir la
fusion du ska folle une aire sera
variable mais variable est mieux que
rien donc ça ça aurait tendance à
rapprocher les milla coït de l'origine
des véritables carnivores après il y
aurait un chevauchement non négligeable
entre les tout derniers miyako idées les
tout premiers carnivores puisque les
tout premiers carnivores sont là dès
l'eocène donc il y aura un sacré
chevauchement et la division entre
miyako idée car niveau rats se serait
faite assez rapidement au final les
miyako ide ont aussi un petit cerveau
donc c'est un caractère primitif qui
n'exclut pas leur origine c'est juste
qu'ils étaient un peu plus primitif il
se brancherait à la base des carnivores
le groupe frère des carnivores et leur
bus leur bulletin panique n'est pas
encore aussi fier donc là vous avez un
petit diagramme qui résume à peu près
tout voilà les millas idées ou miyako
ide dans les millas idées sont une
famille de miyako id mais pour nous le
but c'est de voir la p4 là et m'a alors
que chez les oxygen idée vous avez la
m2m 1
enfin m1 m2 et celle ayez noted et vous
avez m2 m3 voilà donc c'est pour ça que
les millas idées sont placés plus près
des carnivores comme vous le montre
cette phylogénie qui vous montre aussi
que c'est franchement la merde parce que
les miyako is vous avez lévis vers à
vide et vous avez les mii acide et vous
avez même des miyako ide qui finissent
parmi les carnivores donc les miyako id
c'est vraiment un groupe au moins parra
fils éthiques
1 c'est pour ça qu'il a des petites
c'est pour ça que je vous ai mis des
petites
des petites billes mais là c'est un
groupe qui est au moins par affi
l'éthique qui possiblement poliphile
éthique mais qui est certainement voilà
c'est probablement parmi ce groupe que
s'enracine le groupe karnivor ce qui
nous amène maintenant aux véritables
carnivore a donc les véritables
carnivore a qui trouvent une origine
dont les premiers fossiles se retrouve
déjà abondamment à l'eocène on a
quelques traces possibles au paléo scène
mais on est à peu près sûr qu'il ya une
origine paléocène au groupe même si on
n'a pas énormément de fossiles
on est à peu près sûr qu'il ya une
origine paléocène au groupe et vous avez
une division fondamentale qui est très
visible donc sur ce cadeau g
cette division fondamentale entre les
carnivores qui sont plus qu'ils sont qui
sont plus proches parents des chiens et
qu'on va appeler les cas ni forme et les
carnivores qui sont plus proches parents
des chats et qu'on appelle l'effet lee
forme et vous allez voir et on va voir
notamment que les hyènes font partie des
faits les formes et non pas des cas ni
forme donc la division entre cani formé
felli forme elle est soutenue par des
caractères génétiques mais pas seulement
il ya aussi des caractères
morphologiques
donc ça c'est bien et les caractères
morphologiques c'est principalement
c'est principalement le
la carotide donc ça va être
principalement sur la morphologie de la
bulletin panique donc c'est pour ça que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
rappelez-vous les carnivores ont une
bulle tympanique ossifié donc
contrairement aux miyako id
vous voyez cette bulle tympanique
ossifié chez les cannes il chez les
carnivores aussi bien les cas ni forme
que les faits les formes mais ce que
vous allez avoir bien c'est une
différente des différences
morphologiques au niveau de la bulletin
panique donc les cas ni forme ce qui
ressemble à un chien vont avoir une
bulletin panique ou l'hecto tympanique
élan totain panique vont être
complètement aussi fier enfin vous êtes
complètement fusionné il va pas y avoir
de séparation entre eux alors que chez
les chats chez les faits les formes
on va avoir les cte autant paniquer
lanto tympanique qui vont finalement
alors à l'âge adulte ils vont être
complètement fusionné mais il va y avoir
une séparation entre les deux en fait il
ya une crête qui va se former entre les
deux une sorte de mur qui va séparer en
fait la cavité délimité par le lectorat
paniqué lantin panique donc vous avez
deux cavités distinctes contrairement à
contrairement à ce qu'on voit chez les
cas ni forme donc lente autun panique va
avoir sa propre qualité dont quant aux
tympans nick passe qui l'orienté vers
l'intérieur du crâne électorat panique
va avoir sa propre qu'habiter hectos
tympanique qui orientait vers
l'extérieur du crâne
donc en fait là vous voyez qu'une bulle
mais la vérité et c'est pour ça que
l'embryon est important ici
la vérité c'est qu'il ya une séparation
nette entre les deux ici qui n'est pas
présente chez les cas ni forme donc
voilà le registre fossile decagny forme
va jusqu'aux l'éocène celui d'ophélie
forme va jusqu'à le lit gaussen mais
voilà comme les miyako ide sont
quasiment complètement confondus avec
les carnivores ça veut pas dire qu'il y
avait pas des carnivores avant mais la
division entre cani forme effet
difformes ll date très probablement
elle daterait probablement du début de
l'éocène voir comme le suggère ce secret
de grammes de la fin du paléocène bon
évidemment à chaque fois que plus les
fossiles devient dans son ancien et plus
c'est difficile à caractériser bien sûr
et un autre caractère qui est
intéressant quoique plus difficile à
voir
par expérience c'est pas toujours facile
d'arriver à de le voir mais voilà la
carotide laisse un sillon visible sur la
bulle celle ekani forme alors qu'il n'en
laisse pas chez les faits les formes
mais vraiment oui comme je disais très
très difficile à voir donc ça se trouve
à la marge en fait entre la bulle et le
basic occipital donc
donc si vous voyez un petit creux en
fait entre la bulle et le base et
occipital c'est probablement que vous
regardez un cas ni forme alors
commençons déjà par parler des faits les
formes donc là on plonge dans la
diversité des des carnivores en
s'intéressant d'abord à la branche des
faits les formes la branche des faits
les formes ont mal à distinguer des cas
ni forme par par un autre caractère mais
beaucoup plus écologique c'est que les
faits les formes en moyenne sont
beaucoup plus carnivore que les cas ni
forme donc leur régime alimentaire va va
influencer leur anatomie de telle sorte
qu'on va avoir beaucoup plus
d'adaptation à la carne ivory en moyenne
parce qu'il ya évidemment des groupes de
felhi forme qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
pas très fortement adapté à la carne
ivory mais disons qu'en moyenne si vous
trouvez un crâne de carnivores avec vous
voyez ces grosses dans ces grosses
carnassière en forme de m
un museau très très court
et surtout une tendance à la perte des
dents poste carnassière c'est que vous
regardez un film forme donc qu'est ce
que tout ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'en
gros chez les faits les formes les faits
les formes vont être fortement adapter
un régime
de prédateurs de prédateurs dominant du
fait de l'heure de leur adaptation à
l'hyper carnivore il est fait les formes
en fait vont concentrer toute la
puissance de leurs mâchoires au niveau
des dents carnassière ce qui fait que en
fait les dents après la carnassière et
même les dents avant les carnassière
vont devenir de plus en plus redondantes
obsolète
donc on va avoir une tendance évolutive
vers la perte de ses dents des dents
poste carnassière epr et carnassière
donc des prémolaires et des molaires
après les carnassière qui va être plus
prononcé chez les faits les formes que
chez les cas ni forme les cas ni forme
globalement vous allez rencontrer dès ce
qu'on appelle des formules dentaire
complète chez les cas ni forme parce que
les cas ni forme vont pas avoir tendance
à perdre à perdre leurs dents car ils
sont un peu plus omnivore que les faits
les formes les faits les formes
ils vont tout miser sur les carnassiers
et ça ça va de pair avec un régime hyper
carnivores
évidemment comme je le disais avec
variations jeu certains groupes
retournant vers un mode de vie vers vers
un régime alimentaire plus omnivore donc
on va bon bah évidemment il ya les
caractères de la bulle qui sont
importants et il va surtout y avoir la
distribution des carnivores parce qu'on
associe évidemment beaucoup les
carnivores à l'afrique et notamment les
grands félins les faits les formes les
hyènes les lions tous ces animaux là
sont très fortement associé ophélie
forme et bien chez et bien en réalité
les faits les formes ont une origine
asiatique et ça c'est un peu près sûr on
a énormément de fossiles qui viennent de
de l'asie de l'éocène d'asie qui
pointent très clairement du doigt vers
une origine une origine asiatique du
groupe
le groupe déferlant après en europe et
en afrique
donc en europe à la fin de l'éocène et
en afrique au début du miocène
et concurrençant les yellow d'autres
idées qui étaient les carnivores
dominant voici une phylogénie simplifier
un des faits les formes qui est pas
forcément enfin évidemment il ya
toujours débat après sur des sur la
position de certaines espèces certaines
phylogénie place notamment les y ait une
idée plus à la base que
plus à la base de l'arbre que cette
phylogénie là donc c'est pas
complètement exclu que vous trouviez des
phylogénie un peu différente
donc voici les yenni des layènes idées
qui sont très intéressants parce que la
plupart des gens croient qu'ils sont en
fait
associée aux cas ni uniforme okani forme
et en fait non les hyènes idées ne sont
pas des chiens malgré leur comportement
qui est effectivement extrêmement canal
je veux dire la vie en groupe ddd hyènes
tachetées rappelle fortement les meutes
de chiens mais non en fait si vous
regardez leur si vous regardez leur
carnassière leur carnassière est
typiquement celle d'un d'un fêlé forme
et leur dentition vous pouvez voir donc
vous avez là carnassière ici vous avez
une petit résidus de molaire juste
derrière à l'avant de la carnassière
vous avez
soit entre 2 et 3 prémolaires en
fonction de si celle-là est là ou pas
parce qu'évidemment elle est très
résiduel mais voilà vous avez vraiment
cette tendance déjà chez les hyènes à la
réduction du nombre de dents pré et post
carnassière qui est très typique des
faits les formes vous avez le museau
très court des faits les formes
évidemment la seule exception étant
parmi les hyènes idée étant le
le protège donc le pro tell qui est en
fait adapté à un mode de vie fourmilier
inquiets alors qu'il n'est pas un
fourmilier parce qu'il n'a pas encore la
morphologie si typique des fourmis et
mais d'ores et déjà le protêt
l'utilisent sa langue pour pour attraper
des termites et de fait ils avalent
beaucoup de terre ce qui fait que et
bien on constate la réduction des dents
des de toutes les dents quasiment en
tout cas des molaires chez le pro tell
qui est si typique en fait des espèces
qui deviennent qui deviennent qui
acquiert un régime alimentaire
essentiellement me remets coffrage donc
et vous pouvez voir aussi le protêt les
traits caractéristiques avec cette ce
palais est extrêmement extrêmement large
et les hyènes on a de très très on a un
très très beau registre fossile des
hyènes donc et notamment en afrique mais
aussi en europe en europe on a la haine
des cavernes qui est probablement la
plus connue
et en afrique on a donc casse ma porte
et est ce qui est la mienne chasseuse
parce que les hyènes n'ont pas toujours
été des charognards comme ils le sont
aujourd'hui en fait les kasmas porte
était c'était une hyène chasseuse mais
elle avait déjà la dentition traits
typiquement écrase aux dos des hyènes
moderne c'est juste que c'est là les
proportions de ses membres indique que
c'était vraiment une hyène coureuses est
pas une hyène avec l'arrière du corps
penché vers l'arrière pencher vers le
bas comme comme on peut le voir chez les
hyènes moderne donc une autre famille de
carnivore à et que de fait l'effort mien
et que et qui justement illustre un peu
ce que je vous montrais tout à l'heure
la le fait que certaines familles vont
avoir des dents à un peu moins
carnassière et vont notamment avoir une
tendance à conserver les les dents prêts
carnassière et bien ce sont les harpes
et steed et donc les harpistes idées qui
ont un régime alimentaire un peu plus
diversifiée que les que les autres felli
forme ont donc une formule dentaire qui
est un peu plus préservées mais il
s'agit bel et bien de felhi forme et a
lorsqu'il ya ce qu'il ya d'intéressant à
voir chez les harpistes idée c'est le
caractère qui les définit le mieux c'est
la petite taille de la toute première
incisive
donc il ya trois incisive h et les cas
ni chez les
chez les carnivores et la première
incisive chez les harpistes idée est
toute petite elle est toute petite et
pas aligné avec la racine n'est pas
aligné avec les autres incisive elles
sont un peu décalée vers l'avant donc et
ça c'est un caractère typique des
harpistes idée me demandez pas à quoi ça
sert j'en ai aucune idée
mais voilà c'est un caractère qu'on voit
chez le suricate par exemple et alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'à
madagascar il ya un erp et steed et qui
est arrivé là-bas probablement au cours
du miocène et puis qui a rencontré 0
carnivore il était le seul carnivore de
madagascar et il y avait à bouffer du
coup qu'est ce qui l'a fait ben c'est
devenu un chat voilà c'est le fameux
fossat crypto proft donc le fossat de
madagascar si vous vous rappelez du film
quand il crie fou ça
ben voilà c'est lui et ça existe
vraiment et donc c'est un erp et steed
et qui ressemble à mort à un chat il a
toutes les caractéristiques d'un félin
mais ce n'est pas un chat parce que
regarder il a ses petites cette petite
annotation voilà des incisives la
première paire d'incisives est tout
petit
donc voilà pourquoi on voilà pourquoi le
fossat est classé parmi les harpistes
idées et tout ça était évidemment
confirmés par des analyses génétiques et
évidemment la famille la plus typique de
felhi forme ce sont les félidés
évidemment je peux pas aller à travers
toutes les familles parce que l on
chacun des caractères qui requiert
vraiment l'oeil d'un spécialiste
donc je fais vraiment les familles les
plus comment dire les plus typiques
voilà alors les félidés ce sont des
super prédateur ça veut dire les
prédateurs vraiment au sommet de la
chaîne alimentaire
contrairement aux erp et steed et qui
sont des tout petits prédateurs et qui
peuvent être eux mêmes la proie d'autres
prédateurs
il n'y a pas de prédateurs de félidés
voilà donc et les félidés ce qu'ils
valent et caractérisé bien c'est
évidemment les griffes rétractables donc
les griffes rétractables qui donnent à
leurs griffes d'ailleurs cette anatomie
en forme de faucille très
caractéristique très reconnaissable donc
ça les griffes rétractables c'est
vraiment le truc des félidés quelle que
soit leur taille d'ailleurs vous avez
les big 4 ceux qui sont les super
prédateur mais vous avez aussi les small
caps comme le chat par exemple qui font
aussi partie de la famille des félidés
donc la différence la différence majeure
entre les deux étant généralement la
taille évidemment mais aussi la capelle
le fait que les beats cats sont ce
qu'ils sont capables de courir pas de
grogner mais de rugir alors que les
small caps ce sont ceux qui ont la
capacité de ronronner voilà donc les
léopards en fait ce sont des small caps
passe qui ronronne
là ce sont des petits chats la
traduction du mot small caps ne passe
pas du tout en français hélas cette
image là je les aime bien parce qu'elle
vous permet bien de montrer le voile à
la division de la bulle celle effet les
formes et elle montre aussi voyez la
dentition donc vu que là avec les
félidés on attaque du prédateur hyper
carnivores là on voit bien la tendance à
la réduction des dents pré et post
canine vous voyez que là vous avez la
pré et post carnassière là vous avez là
carnassière vous n'avez qu'une seule
prémolaires avant et vous avez rien du
tout après quoi donc
donc là c'est chez eux finalement que
cette tendance à la réduction des dents
surnuméraires on va dire des temps qui
ne sont pas là carnassière va être le
plus poussé
donc si vous rencontrez un crâne un jour
de chat vous le saurez immédiatement
simplement parce que vous verrez une
énorme carnassière et voilà d'erratique
au dedans autour éventuellement quoi
surtout la prémolaires qui va être là
prémolaires numéro 3 qui va être un peu
développée sur le dessus mais c'est tout
quoi le derrière ça plus rien donc
évidemment on a un très très beau
registre fossile de félidés qui
documentent non seulement leur origine
en asie mais ensuite leur migration en
afrique et donc en afrique on a des on a
des fossiles qui sont telles que cela
fait ça c'est une calotte crânienne
d'hominidés d'australopithèques avec
deux trous qui correspondent à
l'espacement qu'on retrouve chez les
léopards
donc voilà la reconstitution de la scène
tels que vous pouvez la voir dans
certains livres
voilà la reconstitution de la scène
telle qu'on peut la voir au musée de
pretoria donc c'est assez gore c'est
assez gore la façon dont dix ont fait ça
mais j'aime bien
j'aime bien donc évidemment les léopards
les léopards ont joué un rôle
prépondérant dans l'évolution des êtres
humains
l ebit 400 général ont joué un rôle
prépondérant dans l'évolution des êtres
humains ne serait ce que parce que les
êtres humains étaient leurs proies et
évidemment le groupe de fait l'idée que
vous attendez tous encore qu'ils ne sont
qui n'appartiennent pas tous au félidé
en réalité eh bien ce sont les
et les saveurs tuft 4 donc les tigres à
dents de sabre en anglais on dit chat à
dents de sabre mais ça claque - du coup
les tigres à dents de sabre donc les
tigres à dents de sabre en réalité celle
effet difforme on va avoir plusieurs
familles de fait les formes qui vont
évoluer la morphologie à dents de sabre
donc vous allez avoir les nîmes raviné
je suis pas complètement sûr qu on les
inclut parmi les félidés je crois que ça
dépend vraiment des auteurs mais pour ça
vous pouvez si vous avez des bonnes
références à ce propos d'ailleurs dans
les commentaires vous pouvez me les
laisser parce que je suis preneur donc
l'énigme raviné qui sont soit le groupe
frère des félidés soit pas du tout des
félidés ont été les premiers à évoluer
la morphologie à dents de sabre donc
enfin les premiers felli forme
évidemment avant ça il ya eu d'autres
groupes qui avaient des dents de sabre
mais les premiers felli forme avec des
dents de sabre ce sont les nîmois vider
avec notamment us milus qu'on rencontre
en europe et qui est très facile à
distinguer d'un tigre à dents de sabre
classiques comme smilodon par le fait
qu'il a ce gros processus sur le menton
et il peut être distingués de ti la qos
minutes parce que le ses canines ne
remonte pas jusqu'au niveau de son
orbite comme chez ti la qos minutes donc
voila ce minus tigres à dents tigre à
dents de sabre de l'oligocène d'europe
très caractéristique et ensuite vous
allez avoir donc ce qu'on appelle les
faux tigre à dents de sabre parmi les
félidés et cette fois c'est sûr c'est du
félidé vous avez deux familles donc les
faux tigre à dents de sabre qu'on
appelle les thèmes étaient l'uriné comme
dino feliz et les vrais tigre à dents de
sabre qu'on appelle les mac héros dont
tinée tels que smilodon donc smilodon
est le véritable fait partie de la
famille des véritables tigre à dents de
sabre comme macairo du ski a donné son
nom à la famille et qu'on retrouve en
europe
il ya notamment
a montpellier on a pu en retrouver au
mot terium qu'on retrouve à travers le
monde -afrique inclus est donc la
différence entre les deux c'est c'est
pas évident à pointer du doigt quoi mais
c'est en gros le processus corot no id
donc le ce à l'arrière de la mâchoire ce
processus qui se projette ici sous
l'arcade du gal est un peu plus grand
que chez les que chez les matières aux
dons idée est d'ailleurs ce processus va
se réduire et devenir de plus en plus
petit au fur et à mesure qu'on a démâté
des matières ou d'anti des hypers
dérivés vous avez aussi chez les ch et
où les tigres à dents de sabre
vous avez une tendance à la réduction du
nombre de dents post canine qui est
encore plus prononcée au point que les
tirs allant de sa voix les plus dérivés
ne vont avoir en fait qu'une seule dent
et ce sera là carnassière donc ladino
feliz s'est pas encore le cas vous avez
encore une prémolaires mais si vous
prenez
ainsi si vous prenez par exemple
smilodon smilodon la dentition est
quasiment uniquement réduite à la dent
carnassière vous avez juste une toute
petite prémolaires à l'avant quoi donc
donc là dedans carnassière devient
encore plus importante encore plus
prépondérante que chez les félidés
classique donc là vous avez trois
exemples qui viennent évidemment
d'afrique puisque c'est un cours que je
donne à mes étudiants sud-africains
il s'agit de barbour ophélie ce qu'on
rapproche souvent denim ravi dé mais
encore une fois c'est discuter c'est
possiblement une famille a parlé barbour
ophélie ce pourrait être les barbour au
félidé vous avez dit no fait l'histoire
les méta du rin et et homo terium pour
les mac héros dont l'idée est évidemment
on peut on peut parler du débat sur à
quoi servaient ces fameuses dents de
sabre donc le l'image qu'on retrouve
beaucoup jeu notamment pour smilodon
c'est que les dents de sabre
finalement elle n'était pas hyper utile
pour la chasse parce qu'elle était trop
fragile alors s'il s'en servait c'était
uniquement pour percer la carotide
une fois que l'animal était immobilisé
par le reste de la troupe
bon ça me paraît un scénario un peu
improbable mais j'avoue je suis pas
spécialiste donc pour ça pour ça je ne
peux pas vous donner une réponse
définitive
en tout cas ce qu'indique le registre
fossile déjà c'est qu'il n'y a pas qu'un
seul type de dents de sabre il ya des
dents il ya des tigres à dents de sabre
comme le smilodon qui ont des dents de
sabre très fine
très fine j'entends par là pas très
épaisse et il ya les tigres à dents de
sabre qui ont des dents de sabre balèze
massive mais gantés rayons par exemple
il a des dents de sabre assez balèze
comme vous pouvez le voir et on a de
bonnes raisons de croire que mega
enterré on se servait de ses dents de
sabre pour chasser et pas seulement pour
percer les carotides une fois qu'il
était plaqué au sol par le reste de la
troupe de mes gants terrien là on a
vraiment des dents de sabre qui sont
capables de percer l'os parce qu'on a
justement un homo erectus avec bing les
deux trous dans le crâne qui
correspondent exactement aux canines de
mes gants des rayons donc donc certains
dents de sabre était quand même capable
de percer l'os avec leurs dents de sabre
mais pour d'autres dents de sabre
évidemment il ya les dents étaient
peut-être trop délicate
on sait aussi que ses dents de sabre
elle n'avait pas qu'une fonction dans la
chasse elle avait essentiellement une
fonction de de sexuel alors il n'y a pas
vraiment de dimorphisme sexuel chez les
dents de sabre au moins pour ce qu'on en
sait mais par contre enfin je veux dire
on sait en regardant la nature actuelle
que les animaux qui ont des grandes
canines s'en servent essentiellement
pour pour les parades sexuelles on pense
notamment aux morses donc le morse qui
est assez gigantesque dents de sabre qui
évidemment ne lui servent pas à chasser
je veux dire elles sont vraiment trop
grotesque donc c'est juste pour la juste
pour la baston entre mâles quoi et pour
savoir qui a la plus grosse
la plus grosse dans évidemment on va
penser notamment aux herbivores qui ont
des dents de sabre comme les chevrotins
rappelez vous je vous ai fait le cours
sur les chevrotins je vous ai montré les
chevrotins on va penser aux cervidés
aussi qu'ils ont des dents de sabre en
fait il ya beaucoup plus d'animaux
herbivores à dents de sabre qui vivent
aujourd'hui que des animaux carnivores à
dents de sabre
donc quand on va me chercher des
exemples de félidés qui ont des canines
un peu grande pour me dire mais si mais
regardent ils arrivent à faire
lassé des canines un peu grande c'est
pas des dents de sabre les seuls animaux
qui vivent aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
vraiment des dents de sabre c'est le
morse et les cervidés et les chevrotins
quoi donc donc et tous les utilisent à
des fins de parades sexuelles donc oui
certains dents de sabre été qu'un
certain tigre à dents de sabre était
capable de percer l'os avec leurs dents
de sabre et là je vous montre notamment
celle ci cet exemple là parce que là je
au dessus je vous ai montré un exemple
de mes gants thereon enfin on a le crâne
d'homo erectus avec les trous qui
correspondent à mes gants thereon mais
là on a vraiment nu rave us donc le
nîmes ravi d qui a ses dents de sabre
planté dans un autre sont les voit même
ressortir de l'autre côté et sept autres
os n'est ni plus ni moins que l'os d'un
autre ni brabus
et c'est là où justement voilà c'est là
où ça ça pointe du doigt vers
l'utilisation sexuelle c'est que
l'endroit où l'on trouve le plus de
blessures de tigre à dents de sabre
c'est pas sur leur proie
c'est sur les autres tigre à dents de
sabre aussi donc les tyrans les tigres à
dents de sabre se servait
essentiellement de leurs dents de sabre
non pas pour la chasse mais probablement
plus pour se [ __ ] sur la gueule
histoire de séduire les femelles et ça
c'est pas anodin et ça c'est directement
les traces fossiles qui nous le montre
c'est à dire que c'est pas de la
spéculation sur la puissance la
puissance simulé de la mâchoire et de
l'ouverture de machin en un an
ça c'est du faux cils ça sert trouve ça
a été retrouvée comme ça voyez donc
donc on sait qu'ils se battaient entre
eux avec leurs dents de sabre on sait
donc que il ce que ce que cette fonction
était essentiellement sexuelle et on
sait qu'ils étaient capables aussi de
percer l'os avec ses dents de sabre au
moins pour nilmar a vu c'est pour mes
gants thereon que je vous ai montré là
donc les dents étaient pas forcément si
fragile que ça au final
mais trêve de dents de sabre parlons
désormais decani forme donc le groupe de
des carnivores qui sont plus proches des
deschiens donc chez les cas ni forme on
va retrouver les ursidés les pros cioni
des donc le [ __ ] laveur les mustélidés
que sont les
les les blaireaux les chiens évidemment
et les loups et les pinnipèdes que sont
les autres y est les phoques
donc évidemment chez eux on va jamais
retrouvé de griffes rétractables mais
déjà ce n'était pas le cas chez les
faits les formes il n'y a guère que les
le wall verrines donc le glouton qui il
me semble est un pro cioni des qui a des
griffes semi rétractable parmi les cas
ni forme mais c'est à peu près le seul
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
wolverine porte le nom de wall verrines
parce qu'il a ses griffes rétractables à
est donc ce qu'on va retrouver chez les
cas ni forme et bien ça va être une
formule dentaire beaucoup plus complète
là vous avez par exemple un loup donc la
mort voilà le loup est probablement l'un
des plus carnivore decani forme et vous
pouvez voir que la formule dentaire est
beaucoup plus complète que celle e felli
forme standard donc beaucoup plus de
molaire retenue de prémolaires retenu à
l'avant donc vous voyez les quatre
prémolaires sont là et vous avez les
trois mots l'air qui sont retenus à
l'arrière sur la mandibule donc voilà la
formule dentaire et préserver beaucoup
plus préservée chez les cas ni forme que
celle effet les formes parce qu'ils ont
un régime alimentaire qui est un peu
plus omnivore voir certains qui sont
complètement mini bord comme les pros
cioni des et les ours
voilà et du coup même chez les traits
carnivores loup on a une dent une dent
carnassière qui à cette forme de m qu'on
retrouve très fortement chez les ch et
les chais les faits les formes mais il
ya aussi un petit halo need qui est
préservée vous pouvez voir ce tableau ni
d'ici qui n'est pas là chez les faits
les formes donc si je retourne chercher
un fait les formes bac jean rembobine
voilà ça c'était un fait les formes vous
voyez la forme du m2 là carnassière mais
il n'y a pas de talent onidi si sur ce
donc ça c'est un puma
si vous vouliez savoir c'est ce truc là
c'est un puma et donc vous voyez il n'y
a pas de talent onid alors que la celle
et chez les cadets forme vous avez
systématiquement avoir un talent onid
même chez les formes très fortement
carnivores et chez des formes très
fortement niveau revoir herbivores parmi
les ursidés vous allez retrouver
retourner vers des dents complètement
plate et une carnassière à peine
identifiables
alors les cas ni formes sont divisés en
deux groupes
encore une fois sur la morphologie de la
bulle donc je sais cette image ressemble
beaucoup à celle que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure mais en fait il s'agit
d'une division à l'intérieur des cas ni
forme c'est une division entre les
chiens en gros entre lessines
donc les ce qui ressemble à des chiens
et les arcs tohid c'est à dire ce qui
ressemble à des ours en réalité on va
voir que à part le goulet à part les
canidés donc les chiens et les loups
tous les autres sont des arcs tohid mais
il ya une dizaine un caractère important
qu'il est défini sur la bulle et c'est
qu'en fait le à l'intérieur de la bulle
donc je voulais dit tout à l'heure il
n'y a qu'une seule cavité contrairement
aux faits les formes qui ont plusieurs
cavités séparés par des délimitations
osseuse bien bien défini mais bien
qu'ils y ait qu'une seule cavité il y a
quand même un petit 1,70 partiel voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle le cepd
sommes partielles donc il ya eu une
petite séparation entre une proto
séparation j'ai envie de dire entre les
cavités de la bulle dans clegg
séparation n'est pas complète mais il ya
quand même un début de septembre qui se
forment donc ça c'est la différence
entre les chiens et les ours
donc voilà et c'est ce que je vous
montrais donc les canaux ide qui sont là
enfin les sino id pardon ils sont lassés
les canidés et les arcs tohid c'est tout
le reste en fait avec les ours à la base
les pinnipèdes donc les pinnipèdes sont
de proches parents des ours sont des
ours adapté à la vie aquatique et vous
avez les après les must héloïse chez qui
vous retrouvez tous les autres tous les
autres canaux id cani forme donc
l'origine de ce groupe donc decani
former et pas super super clair mais en
gros vous avez les offres les amphis
cioni dès qu'ils apparaissent à
l'oligocène et qui dès qu'ils deviennent
très dominant au milieu scène ses amphis
cioni des qui qu'on appelle aussi les
chiens ours sont vraiment des cas ni
forme au sens le plus pur du terme
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
n'appartient ni au sinohydro ni aux arcs
tohid voilà ils n'ont ils ont juste les
caractères qui permette de dire que ces
decani forme et c'est tout ils
n'appartiennent ni à un groupe ni à
l'autre
donc voilà où on pense que se trouve
l'origine des cas ni forme et du fait
qu'ils n'ont que des caractère primitif
pour les définir
je mets des petites guillemets parce
qu'ils sont très probablement par hafid
éthiques voire poliphile éthique ça se
trouve il ya des amphis sioniste
qui sont qui sont plus proches des ours
et d'autres qui sont plus proches des
chiens donc voilà et encore une fois on
a des formes qui ont pu atteindre des
tailles tout à fait respectable comme en
fission giganteus du miocène de namibie
donc alors commençons déjà par les
chiens comme ça on évacue donc les
chiens je vous ai dit tout à l'heure les
cas les canidés donc qui appartiennent
au groupe de synovie donc ils ont cette
séparation partielle de la bulle
c'est aussi de leur côté qu'on va
retrouver les formes les plus carnivore
de les formes qui sont les plus proches
on va dire de super prédateur il n'y a
pas de super prédateur chez les canifs
chez les canidés mais voilà c'est des
formes les plus carnassière on va dire
et donc ce petit ce petit canif forme
ici que vous voyez c'est eux sion qui
montre qu'en fait les canidés sont
arrivés très tard deux en afrique à
partir de l'asie est en fait encore une
fois les canidés on parle d'une origine
asiatique un donc le l'asie c'est
vraiment le centre de diversification
des cadets des carnivores aussi bien des
faits les formes des félidés que decani
formes et des canidés c'est tout en asie
que ça se passe
et puis après ils vont se disperser en
europe ont généralement la dispersion
entre l'europe et l'asie est quasi
immédiate et en amérique au fil des
ponts qui se forme avec l'abe avec la
béringie donc le détroit de béring et
évidemment l'afrique l'afrique qui est
de toute façon au miocène toujours en
connexion avec l'asie et le restera et
donc ici vous avez plaisir gül hop les
yogis l'eau qui est intéressant parce
que c'est un c'est un glouton
or les gloutons on a l'habitude enfin
les wolverines c'est une espèce qui
aujourd'hui n'est limitée que l amérique
du nord donc c'est intéressant de voir
qu'il y avait un glouton finalement en
afrique quelque part au milieu scène
c'est aussi intéressant de voir que
finalement les
une l'afrique a servi de refuge à
beaucoup de l'espèce mais pas tout
voilà les gloutons finalement leur
refuge ça a été la mairie du nord est
pas le et pas l'afrique est alors les
ursidés les les ursidés donc les les
arcs torride les plus basses eaux j'ai
envie de dire eh bien c'est sûr si des
ils sont encore une fois on parle d'une
origine d'une origine plutôt asiatique
en tout cas en eurasie
mais on en photo on en rencontre quand
même en afrique alors il ya que deux
espèces d'ursidés qui ont atteint
l'afrique c'est le l'ours des cavernes
qu'on rencontre en afrique du nord et
que vous voyez à gauche
l'ours des cavernes dont la dentition
voyez les dents extrêmement plate
extrêmement alors extrêmement bruno
dhont mais très usés montre qu'il était
complètement herbivores et on a aussi
des analyses isotopiques qui montre que
le l'ours des cavernes était totalement
herbivores donc c'est un ours qui n'est
même pas omnivore dans ce cas là le
l'ours des cavernes était complètement
herbivores et vous avez une autre espèce
d'ours qui cette fois était recrue
retrouvés jusqu'en afrique du sud et qui
est agrio terium et c'est à peu près le
seul ours qui a eu une distribution
panafricaine quoi pas seulement limité à
l'afrique du nord au bassin
méditerranéen non la grille au terium
c'est le seul qu'on retrouve dans toute
l'afrique et agrio terium pareil la
taille du crâne indique un animal qui
devait flirter vers les hinton donc
encore encore un carnivore géant mais en
l'occurrence agrio terium était plutôt
omnivore et les fossiles sont très très
rares aussi de la grille au terrarium ce
qui est assez impressionnant
donc les ursidés ce qui va vraiment les
caractériser oui c'est leur dentition
qui est extrêmement buno don d'un bras
qui dompter bruno dhont donc une
dentition extrêmement omnivore un peu
comme celle d'un cochon quoi au final
et avec des petites puces pid qui vont
se développer
d comme chez les cochons aussi
c'est aussi parmi les ursidés qu'on va
rencontrer les pandas les pandas qui
sont exclusivement herbivores donc là on
va avoir une dentition qui va ou la
surface dentaire va finalement se
développer chez les chez les pandas donc
pour augmenter une fois de plus la
surface occlusale la surface de
mastication et alors petit fun fact à
propos des pandas c'est que les premiers
fossiles de panda on les retrouve en
europe et non pas en asie donc les
premiers fossiles de panda il date du
miocène moyens et ils ont été retrouvés
en espagne et en france du côté de lyon
donc donc le mieux scène moyens au
miocène moyens les pandas sont apparus
en europe et non pas en asie et après
vous avez une despair encore une fois
dispersion à travers le monde en afrique
en amérique du nord et même en amérique
du sud où les ours à lunettes sont les
descendants d'un groupe très ancien de
dours qui a atteint l'amérique du sud
il y a deux millions d'années les
pinnipèdes alors les pinnipèdes ce sont
les seuls carnivores adapté à la vie
marine et c'est bon c'est déjà pas mal
mais les pinnipèdes ça va être les
carnivores pour lequel on va avoir le
plus de mal à retrouver les la
carnassière parce que évidemment vous
avez la tendance à l'homo dont six qui
on retrouve celle qui est une adaptation
classique chez les espèces qui s'adapte
seconde herman à la vie marine
donc la tendance à le mans dont six qui
va en fait ben a transformé les dents
finalement qui va être qu'ils vont faire
que les dents vont être tout les mêmes
au final donc là carnassière et perdu
chez les pinnipèdes comme vous pouvez le
voir sur cette mandibule et alors vous
voyez même réapparaître la morphologie à
3 accuse pid qu'on a qui était celle
d'aider des synodes honte
en fait donc là on verra plus en détail
la morphologie dentaire dessine au doute
quand on fera les synapses in mais je
vous avais déjà parlé donc que les
signaux dont tu avais trois cuts speed
est donc finalement les pinnipèdes
repartent finalement à la case départ
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec une
adaptation enfin si ça ça a à voir avec
l'adaptation d'un mode de vie avec un
régime alimentaire piscivores mais
finalement ça veut pas dire que les
signaux dont tu étais piscivores quoi
évidemment mais voilà donc le truc
intéressant c'est que la carnassière du
coup est perdu chez ces pinnipèdes mai
mais heureusement on a les plus anciens
pinnipèdes comme puis djila qui vient du
miocène d'amérique du nord donc on
serait plutôt sur une origine nord
américaine avec les pinnipèdes après que
les arcs tohid se soient dispersées en
amérique du nord et chez pugilat vous
voyez il ya toujours un beau complexe un
beau complexe p4 et mains qui se
trouvent toujours là et qui qui indique
bien que voilà on a une origine parmi
les carnivores à pour les pinnipèdes et
puis évidemment pas comme ces classiques
pour pour tout l'est pour tous les
mammifères marins vous avez une
transformation des membres en palettes
natatoire avec élongation des doigts
perte plus ou moins importante de la
mobilité du coude et de et du poignet
donc tous les pinnipèdes ne sont pas
égaux de ce point de vue là les phoques
ont perdu la mobilité du coup de mais
pas les otaries par exemple où les où
les morses et un caractère d'autres
caractère intéressant chez les
pinnipèdes c'est quand vous regardez les
incisives la troisième à six il
ressemble à une canine donc ils ont
toujours une canine
mais la troisième à six il ressemble
aussi à une canine
c'est un caractère qu'on retrouvait
aussi chez le tapir c'est pareil on sait
pas trop ce que ça signifie ça peut être
un usage sexuelle et le foramen lacrymal
est absent ça c'est un caractère qu'on
retrouve à peu près chez tous les
mammifères marins
je n'ai peut-être pas mentionner quand
je faisais le cours sur les cétacés
et évidemment le foramen lacrymal sert à
envoyer de l'eau salée sur la sur les
yeux est évidemment quand vous vivez
dans l'eau vous avez plus besoin de vous
envoyer de l'eau salée sur les yeux quoi
donc évidemment le le foramen lacrymal
donc hélas glandes lacrymales associés
disparaissent chez les mammifères marins
mais voilà ce qui a vraiment intéressant
c'est la halle au monde aussi des
pinnipèdes qui fait disparaître la
carnation au final donc les pinnipèdes
sont divisés en trois groupes
trois groupes qu'on peut aisément
distinguer
d'une part par leur part leur dentition
évidemment elle aussi et surtout par
leur niveau d'adaptation à la vie marine
donc au plus terrestre du spectre
d'adaptation à la vie marine vous avez
les otaries des donc les otaries dès
qu'il y en a qui ont le l'ouverture
nasal qui n'est pas rétracté donc
l'ouverture nasal et terminale il
conserve totalement la mobilité du coude
et du poignet et ils ont de grands bras
ce qui leur permet de marcher en fait
sur le sur la terre ferme donc les si
vous voyez un animal qui marche sur
l'eau en fin pinnipèdes qui marche sur
la terre ferme avec ses quatre pattes et
qui est capable d'applaudir avec ses
pattes avant
c'est une otarie c'est une otarie parce
que les phoques eux en sont incapables
les phoques des îles ils rampent sur la
terre ferme
ils sont incapables de marcher ils ont
perdu la mobilité de des articulations
du bras ou du moins ils ont une mobilité
très réduite dans les articulations du
bras ils ont complètement perdu la
mobilité de l'astragale l'astragale a
développé un respect une espèce
d'excroissances qui bloquent
complètement l'articulation du pied
donc voilà ils sont incapables de
marcher sur la terre ferme et les et les
phoques
ils ont dans une narine beaucoup plus
grande fan des narines beaucoup plus
grande et vous voyez légèrement
rétracter
comme vous pouvez le voir ici il ya un
petit espace ici donc le way sans aller
jusqu'à dire qu'on va peut-être un jour
à voir des phoques avec des évents d'ici
quelques millions d'années c'est en tout
cas le premier pas voilà c'est ce qu'on
voit c'est ce qu'on voyait déjà
notamment je sais pas qui c'est et ça
c'est à peu près le même stade
après vous avez des différences au
niveau de la boîte crânienne
enfin avant même d'attaquer la boîte
crânienne on le sur la tête avant même
d'enlever la
la viande de la tête vous voyez qu'il ya
des petites oreilles chez les otaries il
n'y a pas de petites oreilles chez les
fausses idées
voilà donc pour faire la différence
entre un phoque est une otarie vous
pouvez aussi regarder les oreilles s'il
ya des oreilles c'est une otarie mais
les oreilles sont complètement perdus
chez les fausses idées comme chez les
cétacés et les du gong donc plus
d'oreilles externe et quand vous
regardez le crâne ensuite
donc ça c'est le crâne d'alioune d'un
lion de mer qui est une otarie et sur
les otaries sur les otaries des vous
avez cette espèce de processus au dessus
de l'orbité donc ils forment un plateau
en forme de t avec avec le museau comme
ça qui est complètement absent chez les
otaries dès qu'ils ont un crâne
complètement cylindrique en fait vous
avez aussi cette boîte crânienne qui est
tres ferrique chez les fausses idées
alors que les otaries ont un plus petit
cerveau donc on voit beaucoup plus la
crête sagittale et la crète lampes de
ouidah l'arrière ou crête nucale si vous
préférez à l'arrière voilà un cerveau un
peu plus gros chez les ch et les fausses
idées l'eau mode aussi est plus
prononcée aussi chez les fausses idées
que chez les otaries et enfin les les
morses mal est mort ce qui valait
caractérisé c'est la forme de leurs
tronches quoi parce que quand on a des
énormes défense comme ça ça se lire ça
ne s'invente pas notamment mais les
défenses ne sont présentes que chez les
mâles mais les femelles vont paris fait
encore une fois par effet par pari fait
par ce par effets secondaires on va dire
jeu comme je disais par dommage
collatéral les femelles vont quand même
à voir le bout du museau extrêmement
carré au lieu d'avoir un petit museau
pointu tout mignon par effets
secondaires du développement des
défenses chez les mâles de leur matériel
génétique va la valeur les contraindre à
avoir un gros bout du museau tout carré
comme les mâles et les dans la dentition
des des morses et aussi fortement adapté
à leur régime alimentaire qui est un
c'est essentiellement conclut of ages
donc ils mangent ils mangent des
coquillages donc les dents sont adaptés
à broyer du coquillage ce qui fait
qu'ils ont des dents vraiment très
simple et complètement plate pour
écraser et un dernier petit truc c'est
la façon de nager donc les otaries nage
avec les bras avant alors que les
phoques et les
morse nage avec les pattes arrière voilà
ce qui nous amène au micromammifères ça
y est on attaque enfin la dernière
partie de secours avec les
micromammifères donc je vais surtout
m'intéresser aux rongeurs et aux
chiroptères parce que ce sont les plus
les plus abondants mais on va voir qu'il
ya d'autres micromammifères qui valent
le coup d'être mentionné alors jeu comme
je vous disais les rongeurs les
chiroptères c'est plus de 50% de la
diversité des mammifères voyez ces mêmes
les deux tiers de la diversité des
mammifères donc sur sur 5000 espèces
1500 sont des rongeurs 1200 sont des
chiroptères donc sont des chauves souris
à côté de ça les espèces qu'on a vu donc
les marsupiaux les persos dactyle les
enfin tous les ongulés de manière
générale les carnivores
bah c'est à peu près tout donc forme
même pas un quart de la diversité donc
ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent
c'est même pas un quart de la diversité
des mammifères donc là c'est pour ça je
peux pas je peux pas juste zapper les
micromammifères donc faut bien que je
les cache quelque part où ça va
intéresser les gens et c'est le seul
endroit
le cours des carnivores c'est le seul
endroit voilà bon mais est aussi
l'intérêt des micromammifères c'est
qu'en plus d'être très nombreux
aujourd'hui ils sont très nombreux dans
le registre fossile parce que bah déjà
comme tous les mammifères ils ont des
dents que les la morphologie dentaire de
chaque micromammifères est différente et
on va voir ça notamment chez les
rongeurs mais surtout et ben les
micromammifères ils sont nombreux dans
le registre fossile très très très
nombreux
d'une part parce que bas il y avait plus
de micro il ya toujours eu plus de
micromammifères que de gros mammifères
mais surtout il va y avoir conservation
préservation des micromammifères dans la
danse qui est laid dans les cavernes et
donc ça ça permet de faire deux dates et
les cavernes aussi les couches de
remplissage à l'intérieur des cavernes
donc c'est très utilisé ça a été très
utilisé notamment dans le quercy donc
dans la région du caire 6 et des dépôts
de cavernes qui datent de l'éocène et de
l'oligocène et ça ça a permis de faire
des corrélations entre les cavernes pour
savoir de quand elles dataient ça a
permis de faire des corrélations avec le
bassin de la limagne aussi donc en du
côté de clermont ferrand là le grand
bassin de la limagne qui datent de
l'oligocène et du miocène et ça a permis
de faire des corrélations aussi avec
avec ce bassin a donc évidemment des
corrélations internationale donc voilà
les parce qu'il ya accumulation de
petits mammifères dans les grottes grâce
notamment aux rapaces aura pas ce qu'ils
viennent faire leur pelote de réjection
dans les cavernes et ben on a un très
très beau fossiles registre fossiles de
mammifères de micromammifères donc voilà
un exemple de stratigraphie basé sur les
micromammifères qui nous vient
directement du du sud de la france on
vous reconnaissez peut-être des noms
alors ça c'est plus l'espagne d'ailleurs
que du sud de la france vous avez aimé
vous avez balaruc par exemple qui en
france donc voilà il n'y a pas que des
sites espagnols il ya aussi décident du
décide du sud de la france et donc là en
utilisant en fait en partant du principe
qu'il ya eu une aride une aridi fication
du climat eh bien on a on s'attend à
voir une augmentation de la taille de la
couronne dentaire
surtout sachant que l'équivalent moderne
de ces espèces là à une couronne
dentaire très haute et donc en
arrangeant finalement les les fossiles
de ces deux-là du genre mimo miss depuis
ceux qui ont les couronnes dentaires les
plus basses à ceux qui ont les couronnes
dentaires les plus hautes et bien on
arrive à dire que le site où on trouve
t'elle couronne dentaire est plus
anciens donc balaruc 2 par exemple est
plus ancien que le site où on trouve
telle hauteur de couronnes dentaires
donc valent des gangs à 1
voilà par exemple et après après ça ça
peut se vérifier évidemment c'est une
tendance évolutive qu'on assume comme
étant la bonne chez une espèce de
rongeurs mais après on peut l'attester
chez d'autres espèces de rongeurs parce
que les avantages des rongeurs c'est
qu'il y en a jamais qu'une espèce
donc après on va à la tester chez
d'autres espèces de rongeurs et on voit
si on observe la même tendance en
désorganisant dans le même ordre et on
va tester aussi avec évidemment on va
entre vars coupé ça avec des datations
absolue si possible et on va couper ça
avec des avec d'autres espèces par
exemple des ruminants si on en a donc
mais l avantage des rongeurs c'est que
du coup si la tendance évolutive est
confirmée mais alors là vous avez un
outil d'une puissance incroyable parce
que des rongeurs vous ne manquerez
jamais en tout cas à partir de
l'oligocène
à partir de l'oligocène vous ne serez
jamais à court de rongeurs il y en aura
toujours une tetra chier dans votre
dépôt fossilifère donc une fois que vous
avez réussi une fois une fois que vous
avez une tendance évolutive vous en fait
l'hypothèse vous arrivez à la confirmer
par des datations indépendante mais une
fois que cette tendance évolutive est
confirmée mais vous savez vous avez le
graal le saint graal de la corrélation
bio stratigraphique donc ça c'est ça a
été utilisée évidemment à de très très
nombreuses reprises
et comme je les dis notamment pour les
grottes et du cou et du coup c'est aussi
intéressant au niveau
paléoenvironnements puisque en plus de
la morphologie dentaire qui va changer
avec le paléoenvironnement donc là les
dents qui deviennent ipso d'hondt la
surface dentaire qui augmente vous allez
aussi avoir des changements dans la
morphologie des rougeurs avec adaptation
à la salutation
si vous êtes dans un environnement qui
va devenir de plus en plus ouvert donc
voilà un environnement plus en plus
arides de plus en plus des articles va
voir des rongeurs de forme de la forme
d'une gerbille évolué donc voilà c'est
les rongeurs c'est super intéressant
encore faut-il savoir de quoi on parle
alors les rongeurs appartiennent au
cloud d'ecs lire donc l'aigle here
hop je voulais mais là ils font partie
des oeufs à recompter glee donc je vous
avais dit les oeufs arrco togolais rpt
c'est la contraction du clad des
archontes et du clad d'ecs lire donc
l'église
ils sont là c'est le sait la branche
herbivores du clad des arts conteuse
lire et alors tout l'église se
ressemblent parce que s'il s'agit des
rongeurs et des lapins donc les rongeurs
et les lapins ont ils ont tous les mêmes
caractères ils ont des caractéristiques
très similaires d'une part ils sont
primitivement au moins un plantigrade
mais beaucoup vont évoluer vers un mode
dit j tigre had
voir et puis vont devenir rappeur et
vont devenir coureur et sauteurs donc
mais primitivement le primitivement ils
sont plantigrade comme l'écureuil par
exemple mais surtout au niveau du crâne
vous allez avoir ses incisives à
croissance continue donc
ips lots dont tu qu'on appelle encore
des incisives et pas dé défense parce
qu'elles ont encore de la de l'émail
donc vous voyez la couche d'émail ici
sur la source rongeurs donc ses
incisives ipso d'hôtes vous pouvez voir
qu'elles vont très très loin à
l'intérieur du crâne et donc elles vont
des formes et le crâne de façon à donner
un profil à ces animaux qui est
complètement reconnaissable vous voyez
le profil du crâne du rongeur n'a c'est
tout plat le profil de la mandibule
aussi est très caractéristique du à la
déformation et vous allez aussi avoir
des molaires ips sont donc des molaires
ipso d'hondt plus li na 6 i plus des
incisives ips lots dont tu es entre les
deux et bien vous allez avoir un
diastème un très très long diastème
parce que vous verrez jamais de canine
est très très peu de prémolaires les
souris typiquement bon que trois mots
l'air et basta les la plupart des la
plupart des rongeurs ont perdu au moins
les deux premières prémolaires plus les
canines alors à l'intérieur des églises
comme vous pouvez le voir sur cette
phylogénie on allait lagomorphes et les
rongeurs donc les lagomorphes les lapins
donc ne sont pas des rongeurs ils sont
séparés c'est un 7-1 clad bien à part et
d'ailleurs je note que j'ai fait une
faute au mont rouge heures ici mais
c'est pas grave le les lapins sont un
clad à part des rongeurs qui s'appelle
les lagomorphes et dans lequel on
retrouve évidemment les lapins le lapin
de garenne classique mais on retrouve
aussi le pica le pica qui comme vous
pouvez le voir alors c'est un c'est un
petit lagomorphes qu'on retrouve en asie
en amérique etc notamment à la gomme of
qu'on retrouve au japon et voila voila
si je vous dis j japon si je vous dis
pika si je vous dis un truc qui
ressemble à un rongeur évidemment vous
pensez à pikachu le pica n'étant
certainement pas complètement étranger à
l'inspiration de pikachu
donc voilà pour les rongeurs les
lagomorphes la diversité des lagomorphes
c'est un peu un peu la misère il ya pas
grand chose
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'espèces moderne
de la golf il ya le pica ya le la paille
à les lièvres et puis basta quoi hein
c'est pas c'est pas très très
diversifiée du côté des lagomorphes mais
ils sont tout de même facile à
différencier des rongeurs et alors la
première chose ça va être de regarder du
côté des incisives alors chez les
incisives supérieures et bien les
lagomorphes non pas une perdent
incisives supérieures mais deux donc une
grosse paire qui ressemble à celle des
rongeurs et une petite paire juste
derrière et ça c'est différent des
rongeurs qui eux n'ont qu'une seule
paire d'incisives en plus les incisives
sont complètement entouré des mailles
chez les rongeurs chez les lagomorphes
pardon alors que chez les rongeurs
vous voyez les mailles et limiter
strictement à la face antérieure de
l'incisive donc il ya pas deux il n'ya
pas d'émail à l'arrière de la 2d
incisive des rongeurs alors qu'il y en a
sur les lagomorphes et enfin les
lagomorphes ont une morphologie dentaire
extrêmement simple vous pouvez voir la
morphologie dentaire est très simple
chez les lagomorphes vous avez cédant de
forme ovale avec un seul nov
au milieu et ça c'est très
caractéristique des lagomorphes donc une
morphologie dentaire qui est très très
simple et encore une fois ça permet de
comparer aux rongeurs qui ont des
morphologies dentaire absolument
exubérante
donc c'est très facile de reconnaître si
vous avez à la golf
la dernière chose pour reconnaître un
bon crâne de lapin ou de lièvre c'est la
pneumatique à sion du maxillaire donc le
maxillaire il a cette espèce de textures
complètement troué en fait et ça c'est
vraiment typique des lapins et des
lièvres chez le pic à vous n'avez pas
cette texture mais par contre il y à une
fausse donc il ya une une dépression à
l'intérieur du maxillaire au même
endroit donc c'est pour ça que je mets
maxillaire pneumatiques et ça compte un
peu pour tous les lagomorphes même si la
morphologie est pas exactement la même
entre les pics à et les lièvres et donc
par opposition on a les rongeurs donc de
l'autre côté de la force d'église on a
les rongeurs et alors chez les rongeurs
on a une
on a donc déjà une batterie dentaire
extraordinaire des dents extrêmement
complexes qui vont agir les yeux les
unes sur les autres d'avant en arrière
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle une une
mastication propal inhalent donc il n'ya
pas de mastication sur le côté ou ou de
autant bah non c'est une mastication qui
fonctionne d'avant en arrière donc si
vous regardez l'articulation de la
mâchoire
chez les rongeurs lé cylindrique mais le
cylindre n'est pas latéral il est
enterré au postérieur quoi donc c'est un
cylindre qui est fait pour bouger
d'avant en arrière alors que chez la
plupart des mammifères vous verrez un
cylindre qui est qui et qui est
finalement dans l'autre sens quoi
perpendiculaire qui est perpendiculaire
à l'axé du crâne
voilà donc déjà il ya salle et les dents
sont extrêmement complexes et adapté à
un mode de mastication tout à fait
différent vous voyez généralement les
dents même pointe sur le côté comme ça
ce qui va de pair avec la mastication
propre aline al et puis vous avez les
incisives dit qui comme je le disais il
y en a qu'une paire contrairement aux
lagomorphes et elle est recouverte des
mailles uniquement sur la face avant est
des fois elle est bien orangé comme ça
ça permet de l'avoir très très
facilement et alors les ce qu'il faut
savoir à propos des rongeurs c'est déjà
on est capable d'identifier n'importe
quelle espèce
rien qu'avec sa morphologie dentaire et
là je vous ai mis qu'un tout petit
échantillon de morphologie dentaire chez
les rongeurs mais vous pouvez voir que
la morphologie dentaire est extrêmement
diversifié et elle ne peut pas se
réduire d'ailleurs j'en profite aux
simples termes que je vous ai donné la
dernière fois c'est impossible de
décrire avec seulement cinq mots toute
la diversité morphologique des rongeurs
vous voyez des des dents en forme de l
là vous avez des dents alors elle sort
elle au fond d'autres mais vous voyez
que la dernière est hyper hyper grosse
comparé aux trois autres
ici vous avez une morphologie below
fondante et puis ici vous avez je sais
pas quoi et ça c'est je sais pas quoi
non plus voyez les toutes ces
morphologie dentaires sont différentes
et chaque espèce à une morphologie
dentaire différentes donc ils sont très
faciles à identifier si vous vous y
connaissez
mais voilà le seul truc qui est à mon
avis vaut le coup pour vous d'être
d'être rappelé c'est morphologie
dentaire extrêmement complexe et
extrêmement diversifiée voilà ce qui les
oppose justement lagomorphes et parlant
de diversité justement il faut arrêter
de simplifier les rongeurs à seulement
les souris voilà les rongeurs c'est pas
que des souris il ya des tas de trucs à
l'intérieur des rongeurs vous n'avez
même pas idée donc le l'exemple le plus
connu c'est évidemment le râteau tenue
et oui le fameux rate obtenu africa qui
a enfin déjà c'est une grande famille
les rattes obtenu faut pas seulement les
enfin les rats taupe c'est une très très
grande famille et faut pas la limiter
seulement au râteau tenue mais le rate
obtenu c'est l'exemple le plus extrême
de par sa morphologie déjà les dents qui
sont extrêmement projeter vers l'avant
de par la tronche de l'animal de manière
générale et de par le fait qu'il vit
comme une vraie société donc comme des
fourmis avec une reine qui qui est la
seule à se reproduire
et puis des petits soldats et des
ouvriers voilà ils vivent entièrement
sous terre ils ne sortent jamais c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont des tout petits yeux
et la peau nue voilà et on sait pas trop
pourquoi mais ils ont une résistance
accrue aux cancers mais peut-être qu'un
jour on saura ça pourrait être utile
évidemment vous avez les trucs qu'on
appelle des écureuils volants mais qui
une fois de plus ce ne sont pas tous des
écureuils parce qu'en finale
l'adaptation à une locomotion planeur
n'est pas n'est pas arrivé qu'une seule
fois chez les chez les rongeurs n'y a
pas que chez les écureuils que c'est
arrivé il ya chez plein d'autres groupes
de
de rongeurs et les écureuils ne sont
qu'un groupe
ce n'est qu'un groupe le groupe d sur id
la famille déçue rider mais il ya
d'autres familles qui ont évolué vers un
mode de vie planeur et donc voilà par
exemple
l'écureuil volant à que écailleuse donc
vous voyez là que ici avec les écailles
qui n'est pas du tout un sur id mais
qu'on appelle quand même abusivement un
écureuil volant et là vous avez un autre
rongeurs donc c'est un très gros rongeur
qui ressemble beaucoup à la pince et pas
du tout à lapins donc son nom en anglais
c'est springer donc le rongeur qui le
sait le lelièvre sauteur mais ne nous y
trompons pas c'est bel et bien c'est bel
et bien un rongeur est pas lagomorphes
et vous voyez le crâne ici qui est
typiquement celui d'un rongeur avec une
seule paire d'insuline et puis quand on
commence à regarder dans le passé alors
là c'est encore mieux
vous avez les rongeurs alors les castors
parce qu'apparemment il serait relié aux
castors donc les rongeurs mis la gaule
idées qui sont des castors fouisseurs et
avec des cornes sur le nez voilà donc ça
c'est la taille d'un castor vous voyez
les énormes pâte avec des griffes à
l'avant qui montre que c'était une
espèce fouisseurs et donc il vivait
pendant le mieux c'est notamment en
amérique du nord
et ils seraient les responsables des des
monnaies l'x donc les démones helix ce
sont les terriers en forme de spirale
qui sont très célèbre en amérique du
nord et vous avez josepho artigues asia
de l'amérique du sud
on parlera des rongeurs sud américain
joseph aux artigues asia le rongeur
d'amérique du sud qui était à peu près
de la taille d'un rhinocéros ou pas loin
voilà vous voyez comparer un rat moderne
joseph aux artigues à dia c'est du gros
seins ceux du gros passé à rhinocéros
mais un rhinocéros de sumatra
voilà on va simplifier les choses parce
que je sens bien que des gens vont me
dire ouais mais un rhinocéros a pesté le
poids way rhinocéros de sumatra allez
allez donc voilà et alors justement les
rongeurs sud américain
comment les rongeurs sont arrivés en
amérique du sud parce que les rongeurs
de base c'est encore une fois un groupe
qui a son origine en asie alors asia
teria donc l'histoire des rongeurs
d'amérique du sud c'est une histoire
assez fascinante céder donc les rongeurs
d'amérique du sud
ils apparaissent dans le registre
fossile il ya 40 millions d'années et en
fait ils sont sortis de nulle part
donc on est allé aux scènes supérieur il
n'ya pas d'ancêtres potentiel en
amérique du sud pour ces rongeurs qui
ont été retrouvés dans les dépôts du
paléocène et de l'éocène et de l'éocène
inférieurs et moyens et d'un seul coup
vous avez des rongeurs complètement
formés qui apparaissent en amérique du
sud au à l'eocène supérieur et donc et
c'est en fait c'est un c'était une
grande question d'où sont sortis cetc
auront joueur sud américain est en fait
la réponse elle nous est donnée par la
morphologie des rongeurs sud américains
modernes
donc il faut il ya un truc qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les rongeurs moderne
ils ont informé nafkha orbitaire donc si
vous prenez le crâne d'un rongeur
moderne il y à fort à mes d'infra
orbitaire que vous voyez ici et se fera
mais d'un foire aux buteurs vous voyez
que classiquement il est petit mais les
rongeurs sud américains eux ils ont un
foramen un franc orbitaire qui est
absolument gigantesque donc là vous ce
que vous voyez ce n'est pas le lien
l'orbit telle est la sas et le foramen
infra orbitaire et se fera mais n'a
froid orbitaire il est énorme non pas
parce qu'ils avaient une trompe au 1er
trim ossur développé il ya le nerf
trijumeau qui va dans le nerf dans le
foramen un franc orbiteur mais il ya
surtout le muscle master médian donc le
un muscle mastic ateurs qu'ils passent
par ce trou et qui va ça qui va
s'accrocher
ici sur l'angle de la mâchoire donc ce
muscle master médian pardon pas sur
l'angle de la mâchoire mais sur cette
crête là que vous voyez sur la mâchoire
donc le muscle master médian ils passent
par là ici il est accroché là et il va
se passer par là et s'accrocher ici sur
la crête du crâne et il est extrêmement
développé chez tous les rongeurs sud
américain donc tous les rongeurs
sud-américains ont un énorme foramen
infra orbitaire
alors que si on regarde le crâne de
souris classique alors le muscle masse
était remédier en passe effectivement
par le trou par ce trou infra orbitaire
mais il est beaucoup plus petit donc ça
c'est la morphologie classique des
rongeurs normalement est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant et bien c'est que les les
seuls autres rongeurs chez qui on trouve
cette morphologie de avec le foramen
infor biterre aussi gros et bien ce sont
les porcs-épics africains donc les
porcs-épics d'afrique ils ont aussi vous
voyez un gros faux ramène un froid
orbitaire avec cette zone d'attache pour
le muscle master médian donc le nom de
genre c'est istres x chez le ch et le
porc-épic et la morphologie s'appelle
istres iconia tu est d'ailleurs tout le
clad des rongeurs sud-africain s'appelle
les istrie cogliati les istrie cogliati
donc les mâchoires district ce district
s'étend le porc-épic donc le porc-épic
africains parce qu'il ya plusieurs
espèces de porc-épic la morphologie
porc-épic a évolué plein de fois
commencée pas tout compliquer ceci dit
le porc-épic américain qui est le
porc-épic le plus connu est aussi un
district aube net sauf que ils se
branchent pas à la base de la phylogénie
comme ici se branche en fait tout en
haut un mais voilà donc les porcs-épics
son sont le groupe frère finalement d
istres iconia tu sud américains les
historiques omniahd sud-américains qui
forment l'entièreté des rongeurs qu'on
trouve en amérique donc les chinchillas
les cochons d'inde tout ça ce sont les
tout ça ce sont des les rongeurs qu'on
trouve en amérique du sud
donc voilà les porcs-épics sont
directement le groupe frère finalement
des rongeurs d'amérique du sud ce qui
indique donc que d'un ancêtre commun
africain parce que je rappelle que les
rongeurs sont originaires d'asie se sont
dispersés en afrique très très tôt ils
n'ont ils n'ont pas attendu le mio scène
les rongeurs un déjà à l'eocène ils sont
là
je pense même qu paléocène ce serait pas
surprenant qu'on en trouve mais voilà
les rongeurs ils n'ont pas attendu le
milieu scène pour arriver en afrique et
et ils n'ont pas attendu que le
que le panama se forme pour aller en
amérique du sud ils ont traversé
directement l'atlantique
donc voilà plus 40 millions d'années
avant christophe colomb ils ont traversé
l'atlantique et alors comment c'est
possible ce miracle et ben en fait il ya
des rats d'eau qui se forme à chaque
crue en fait il ya des radeaux qui se
forment donc vous avez des grands
fleuves en afrique et à l'époque il y
avait déjà des grands fleuves en afrique
qui est des crues sauf quand des crues
se forme et bien il ya des morceaux de
mangrove toute entière qui sont arrachés
de la côte est qui sont envoyées à la
dérive dans l'océan atlantique sauf que
partant d'afrique
partant de la côte atlantique d'afrique
quand vous partez à la dérive
vous partez pas dans n'importe quelle
direction vous partez directement vers
l'afrique vers l'amérique du sud par le
courant naturel des alizés enfin il ya
les vents des alizés qui vous pond qui
vous pousse naturellement il ya le
courant des marins qui vont dans le même
sens et qui vous pousse naturellement
vers l'amérique du sud
donc eh ben on pense que c'est comme ça
que les rongeurs ont traversé
l'atlantique à l'époque faut savoir
aussi que l'atlantique était deux fois
plus petit à l'époque un lame et
l'afrique et l'amérique du sud était
deux fois plus proche
il y avait 1000 km2 - entre les deux
donc ça ça aide aussi et pourquoi pas
une origine nord américaine et bien tout
simplement parce qu'il n'y avait pas
district sonné at en amérique du nord
il ya zéro istrie comme inertes en
amérique du nord donc donc donc la plus
la plus possible la plus plausible des
explications c'est celle du radeau du
radeau naturel à la dérive
il ya 40 millions d'années et fait
intéressant en fait même les parasites
en fait des rongeurs américains sont les
mêmes que les parasites des rongeurs
africain est donc même c1 quand on
compare aux parasites des rongeurs
d'amérique du nord
c'est pas du tout du tout les mêmes donc
même si vous partez du principe que les
rongeurs d'amérique du nord sont devenus
istrie cognac en arrivant en amérique si
vous parce que vous en amérique du sud
parce que vous voulez pas croire que les
rongeurs ont traversé l'atlantique et
ben après va falloir expliquer pourquoi
les parasites des rongeurs sud
américains sont en fait les mêmes sont
les mêmes que ceux de
d'afrique alors qu'ils sont différents
de ceux des rongeurs d'amérique du nord
voilà phare a expliqué comment ils ont
ça veut dire que les parasites ont
traversé tout seul quoi c'est ça à 100
les rongeurs là c'est dommage
bon et puis tout ça c'est un scénario
qui est aussi soutenu par la génétique
et et en fait on pense même que les
primates ont fait la même chose et là je
vous renvoie à notre épisode sur le
marsupilami qui était le deuxième dans
le troisième épisode de la chaîne donc
faut remonter loin là faut faire de la
spéléo sur la chaîne pour aller le voir
et on parle de cette théorie justement
avec le sur l'épisode du marsupilami
maintenant qu'on a fini avec les
rongeurs
parce que j'en parlerai pas plus que ça
il ya tellement tellement tellement à
raconter sur les rongeurs mais on peut
juste pas passer trois mois parler des
rongeurs vous imaginez bien que 1500
espèces ça se résume pas en 20 minutes
donc voilà je suis désolé de pas plus
parler des rongeurs
si vous me faites un plébiscite et qu'on
atteint le million de vues promis je
fais une émission entière sur les
rongeurs et elle fera trois heures voilà
ça n'arrivera jamais alors du coup on
passe aux chiroptères donc le deuxième
groupe de mammifères le plus diversifié
est le seul à être complètement capable
de voler par vol battu donc là on a
dépassé le stade de l'écureuil volant 1
là on est sur du vol battu et alors là
où on est emmerdé avec les chiroptères
c'est qu'il s'agit des meilleures amies
des créationnistes parce que pour autant
qu'on sache les plus vieux fossile de
chiroptères qu'on est bas sont déjà des
chauves souris dans tous de tous les
points de vue en fait donc là vous avez
icaro nick terry ce qui est le plus
vieux chiroptères qui datent de l'éocène
inférieur d'amérique et et puis bah
c'est une chauve-souris quoi donc vous
voyez déjà l'élongation des doigts 2 3 4
et 5 qu'on retrouve ces chauves-souris
moderne et qui sert à attendre la
membrane qui leur sert à voler vous avez
déjà toute l'anatomie typique d'un
chiroptères quoi donc les seuls
caractère pour lesquels pour lesquels
icaro nick terry c'est un peu plus
primitifs c'est déjà l'oreille donc
l'oreille
chez les chauves-souris moderne du moins
chez une grande partie des
chauves-souris moderne on va voir qu'il
ya des petites variations mais à les
adapter à l'audition des hautes
fréquences pourquoi parce qu'elles
utilisent les colocations donc et icare
onic terrisse n'était pas adapté à
l'écholocation donc là vous avez
l'oreille interne une chauve souris vous
avez la représentation sur la
radiographie de l'arrière du crâne et
vous pouvez voir que l'arrière du crâne
il est largement dominé par cette
oreille interne l'oreille interne elle
prend une place considérable à l'arrière
du crâne donc sicard onic terrisse
l'avait on l'aurait on le saurait je
veux dire s'il y avait ça chez i car au
nict hérisson ne saurait donc icaro nick
terry c'était probablement pas adaptée à
l'écholocation donc c'était probablement
une chauve-souris dit urnes donc qui
vivait pendant le jour et puis aussi car
au nict et rhys hill à cette longue
queue qui est un peu plus primitives les
chauves-souris moderne non pas une
longue queue ils ont une queue très très
courte
donc voilà c'est les deux caractères qui
rendit canonique terrisse plus primitifs
qu'une chose qu'une chauve-souris
moderne alors pour tout le reste c'est
une chauve-souris et vous avez notamment
la dentition la dentition des
chauves-souris qui qui est très
fortement à l'oc dos don'ts comme vous
pouvez le voir ici
il ya aussi à un os donc il ya une
hausse supplémentaire dans le poser sur
le calcanéum qui soutient le battage yom
qui n'est il me semble pas présent chez
i car onic terrisse donc voilà le
passage y sommes c'est la membrane c'est
la membrane donc chez les chauves-souris
pouf la membrane elle rejoint le
calcanéum il ya un petit os
supplémentaires ensuite allez tendu
jusque vers là que la queue qui n'est
donc pas étendu vers l'arrière comme ça
là que s'arrête juste après le bassin
donc pouf on atteint le bassin bon
revient là et on
mais voilà le sinon oui voilà le truc
c'est que on n'a vraiment pas en a on a
beaucoup de fossiles de chauves souris
mais aucun qui nous indique vraiment 12
ul sorte
voilà donc il ya notamment deux
hypothèses qui se battent sur l'origine
des chauves souris
est-ce que les chauves souris étaient
d'abord et colocatrice et sont ensuite
devenus des animaux volants c'est parce
que les temps rec par exemple les temps
règles qui sont des petit insectivore
africains dont on parlera dans quelques
diapos sont capables de faire les
colocations donc ils sont nocturnes il
fonde les colocations et ils vivent
essentiellement ben voilà il vivait
essentiellement la nuit mais il ne vole
pas là et vous avez l'hypothèse
alternative qui est est ce que les
chauves-souris ont d'abord appris à
voler et ont ensuite appris à faire de
l'écholocation pour pour s'adapter aux
modes de vie nocturne
ce qui serait l'hypothèse raisonnable
enfin ce qui est un mode de vie des
urnes pour les chauves souris est
embêtant parce qu'il ya déjà des oiseaux
en fait qui occupe la même niche
écologique mais bon bah icaro nick
terrisse pour autant qu'on en sache de
toute façon il fait pas les colocations
donc ça résout le problème en fait ça
résout le problème ça semble placer
l'origine des chauves souris en pleine
journée
donc s'il ya d'intéressant avec les
colocations c'est que la convergence
avec les cétacés est presque parfaite en
fait tellement parfaite en fait il ya un
gène qui code pour une protéine qui est
très importante à l'intérieur de
l'oreille qui s'appelle la prestine est
en fait si on fait une phylogénie de la
prestine enfin si on fait une folie au
génie des chauves souris
et une fille au génie des mammifères
j'ai envie de dire plutôt uniquement
basée sur le gène de la prestine voilà
l'arbre que vous obtenez cet arbre en
fait ils placent les chauves souris
comme groupe frère des cétacés
mais seulement des cétacés qui font les
colocations donc seulement des hautes
eaux cette
et ça c'est quand même balèze je trouve
ça quand même super balèze et alors vous
avez les chauves souris les rares chauve
souris qu'ils ne font pas les
colocations qui sont groupe frère de des
chauves-souris qui pratiquent les
colocations et des dauphins ce qui
semble indiquer que les colocations a
été perdue chez ces animaux et pas
seulement parce et pas qu'elle a jamais
été acquise en fait ces chauves-souris
ont perdu la capacité de faire les
colocations en fait elle pratique une
forme des colocations rudimentaire donc
voila voila comment ça a l'air de s'être
passé donc ça veut pas dire que les
chauves-souris son groupe frère des
cétacés pas du tout ça veut dire que
faut jamais perdre de vue que même si
j'en sens totalement les fils au génie
basé sur les caractères moléculaire et
même si au début j'ai déclaré que je
suivrai la phylogénie par les caractères
moléculaire parce que c'est eux qui ont
gagné et c'est tout faut jamais perdre
de vue que quelle que soit la phylogénie
que vous regardez il s'agit d'une
phylogénie de caractère et que c'est en
fait c'est l'auteur de la phylogénie qui
déclare si oui ou non c'est l'arbre qui
l'obtient en utilisant ces caractères la
représente l'évolution de l'espèce est
représentative de l'évolution de
l'espèce parce que ce que vous avez
c'est un arbre de caractère et c'est à
vous de décider arbitrairement
si vous trouvez que cet arbre de
caractère est suffisamment bon pour être
considéré comme un arbre
d'évolution des espèces donc voilà c'est
la petite c'est la petite mise en garde
j'aime bien depuis puisqu'on puisqu'on
parle de phylogénie justement bail à la
classification des chiroptères
généralement enfin traditionnellement
considère les chiroptères divisé en deux
branches donc la branche des méga
chiroptères donc les gros chiroptères
qui vivent en plein jour et qui mangent
des fruits donc il s'agit des des
roussettes donc voilà les roussettes
sont des méga chiroptères les plus
connus donc se sont ils sont strictement
frugivores donc c'est pas là que vous
rencontrerez les chauve souris vampire
vous en faites pas et donc il pratique
une écholocation très rudimentaire et on
les oppose donc on micro chiroptères
qu'ils sont tout petits qui sont
nocturnes et qui pratique une
écholocation très sophistiqués ils sont
très adaptées à l'écholocation et vous
pouvez voir les différences flagrantes
la forme du nez qui est très qui est
très affecté par le fait que c'est par
le nez que son produit les click & co
locatif la forme des oreilles qui est
pareil très modifiée pour la réception
des clikeco locatif une fois qu'ils ont
rebondi donc voilà ces micro chiroptères
donc été considérés comme formant un
clad tandis que les méga chiroptères
former un autre clad et donc le clad des
micros chiroptères étant beaucoup plus
diversifiée que celui des méga
chiroptères avec des espèces qui mangent
des fruits du nectar des insectes et
évidemment les vampires donc les
vampires sont des micros chiroptères
dont il n'y a pas à s'inquiéter c'est
des petits animaux et donc on voit voilà
comment ils étaient divisés avant méga
chiroptères d'un côté micro chiroptères
de l'autre sauf que les analyses
génétiques une fois de plus veulent tout
[ __ ] en l'air en vous mettant quelques
certains groupes de micro chiroptères
plus proches parents des méga
chiroptères que d autres micro
chiroptères et donc on finit avec une
classification qui est toujours bifide
toujours divisée en deux mais avec cette
fois un clad appelé lénine chiroptères
donc les d'après le yin et le yang donc
le conte oppose donc au yang chiroptères
voilà donc le yin et le yang opposé dans
la phylogénie des chiroptères
merci les mercis les généticiens d'en
avoir d'avoir encore rajouter des noms
compliqués et puis après vous avez tout
ce débat sur la position de
phylogénétique des chiroptères donc
comme je voulais dit il y avait un débat
qui avait lieu encore il ya quelques
années sur est ce que les chiroptères
sont des archontes aux glières où des
lots razia terre maintenant le débat est
clos et on considère que les chiroptères
sont dès lors asia terre maintenant la
question c'est la position parmi les
lots radiateur parce que vous avez la
position des chiroptères en tant que
laure asia terre bazzo et laissant les
laissant les cétacés les persos dactyle
et les carnivores former un grand clac
tous ensemble ce qui semble logique quoi
on est plutôt sur un club voilà on
aurait comme je voulais dire on est sur
des mammifères bazzo des placentaires
bazzo qui sont des petits êtres nocturne
et insectivores bon ben voilà on arrive
on arrive celle au radiateur avec un
petit animal nocturne insectivores on va
vers les eaux l'ipo tiff là qui sont des
petits animaux essentiellement
insectivores pas tous nocturne mais
voilà on aurait les chiroptères des
petits animaux insectivores et nocturnes
et puis après on aurait les grands
ongulés et les grands carnivores dit
urnes et bombasse voilà ça fait sens
d'un point de vue écologique cette
phylogénie oui mais c'était sans compter
les les
les événements phylogénétique rares et
les filles et les fils au génie basé sur
le génome et les rétros opposants et les
transposons et oui quand on regarde les
avais trop opposant les transposons et
ben les chiroptères ici donc les
chauves-souris forme d'un cloud avec les
chevaux et les carnivores
[Rires]
alors ils n'ont pas inclus les îles ont
pas inclus les pangolins mais voilà en
gros vous auriez les chiroptères kiffant
mike ladd avec les chevaux et les
carnivores alors vous vous rappelez
quand j'ai parlé d
17 artio d'acted et des persos d'haïti
je vous ai dit qu'il ya une hypothèse
qui lie les a reçus au tactile et les
cet art sud actif dans le cloud & young
natale et the ongulés les vrais ont vu
les bombes à l'aller ils peuvent aller
se faire engueuler 1 comme dirait
l'autre roi parce que c'est plus un
clown monofil éthique maintenant
périssol d'activer cet arsenal est il là
on aurait les chiroptères groupe frère
dépérissent au tactile et des carnivores
hypothèse qui a donc été et les gammes
élégamment baptisé du nom du pégase donc
le cheval ailé donc le clad s'appelle
les pegaso féret à ferraille donc pegaso
en référence au cheval ailé et ferrat et
en référence aux carnivores
voilà donc et l'hypothèse des faits
pegas offert à s est celle qui a le plus
de soutien dans les phylogénie récente
c'est pas après si vous faites un conte
brut du nombre de phylogénie qui trouve
le clac dp gaz aux ferrailles l'épée
gassot ferrat et vont pas forcément
gagné mais par contre si vous faites un
conte brut défilent au génie par contre
il vous fait un compte d phylogénie
récente qui retrouve les picasso ferrat
et et j'entends par récente moins de 4
ans bah là vous trouverez quasiment que
des pegaso ferraille
vous trouverez rien d'autre donc les
phylogénie qui incorpore le plus de
donner au final sont celles qui
soutiennent le club des pays aux
ferrailles
donc il va falloir aussi pareil commencé
à faire notre deuil de la logique de ce
point de vue là et puis voilà
les chiroptères auprès des chevaux amen
voilà donc là on a vu les deux groupes
de deux les deux groupes de mammifères
les plus diversifiés et de micros
mammifères les plus diversifiés donc
l'église et les chiroptères
voilà qui sont là donc chacun dans
l'izoard qu'autour de lire les
radiateurs ya pas de micromammifères
parmi les exonère par contre on va
parler quand même un petit peu de ce qui
se passe de ce côté-là de l'arbre des
afro teria donc si vous vous rappelez
les afro teria il ya deux clad le clac
des paiements gül et donc les affreux
terre qui ressemble à des ongulés et le
clac des afro insectes y filia nous on
va focaliser sur les affres aux insectes
ivorra voilà parce que déjà c'est plus
facile de se rappeler de afro insectes
ivorra les insectivores africain alors
qu'un froid assez ctif il ya c'est quand
même casse pieds donc on va se focaliser
un peu sur les affres aux insectes
ivorra parmi les afro affective aura on
a les maquereaux c'est l'idée est donc
les maquereaux c'est l'idée qu'on
appelle aussi les les rats à trompe pas
voyez pourquoi je veux dire ce sont des
ce sont des petits animaux qui ressemble
à des derbys avec une trompe et donne
pour le coup le qualificatif haha trompe
s'applique pas trop mal parce que les
maquereaux c'est l'idée sont plutôt
herbivores qu'un secte ivor en réalité
vous voyez les dents par exemple les 2 2
puis l'éocène ça c'est un maquereau
c'est l'idée de l'éocène reconstitué à
partir de ce qu'on en connaît c'est à
dire un peu de un peu dos du tarse d'une
oreille interne et des mâchoires
donc vous pouvez voir que sur ses
mâchoires que les dans son carré donc
depuis les eaux seine les maquereaux
c'est l'idée ont développé un gros
iphone et ce gros iphone
ce gros hypo connu et il est le signe du
d'adaptation à un régime herbivores donc
les maquereaux ses idées sont en réalité
essentiellement herbivores leur
distribution est strictement africaine
ce qui va de pair avec leur leur
position phylogénétique parmi les afro
terre d'autres caractéristiques du
groupe basse et la fusion des tares donc
les tarifs sont fusionnés ce qui est une
adaptation au saut et évidemment ils ont
une trompe
et alors de façon intéressante cette
trompe n'est pas homologue à la trompe
des vrais éléphants bon on a vu que les
éléphants ont effectivement commencé
leur histoire sans trompe donc déjà ça
devrait pas être une surprise à ce
niveau là mais surtout quand on dissèque
les muscles en fait on se rend compte
que c'est pas du tout les mêmes muscles
qui participent ou du moins pas dans les
mêmes proportions à la trompe des macros
c'est l'idée et à celle des éléphants
donc voilà et on a un très très beau
registre fossile des macros ses idées
donc qui va jusqu à l'eocène vous voyez
ici on les trouve très abondamment dans
des dépôts de grottes
mais voilà le truc c'est que pour autant
qu'on en sache les maquereaux c'est
l'idée de l'éocène sont déjà assez
similaire quand même mon mac row ses
idées modernes donc c'est c'est pas
comme je voulais dit un des grands
espoirs de la paléontologie c'est
d'arriver à trouver à quoi l'ancêtre
commun des afro terre ressembler et bon
bah c'est de manière générale c'est pas
en regardant du côté des infos à
selective aura qu on le saura pas ce que
les maquereaux ses idées sont ceux qui
ont le probablement le meilleur registre
fossile et voilà il ressemble beaucoup
au maquereau s'est dit des modernes
quoi qu'il arrive donc les tran les
temps décidé les crises au chloride et
ils forment ensemble ce qu'on appelle le
clad d je veux leur mais là donc les
affres aux souris sida y aller tant rec
qui ressemble effectivement à des
musaraignes mais évidemment les taupes
doré que dont vous voyez le crâne l'art
semble pas des musaraignes ressemblent
plus à des toc mais voilà le clac
s'appelle afro saurai sida dont elle est
enracinée les crises au chloride et ils
partagent pas mal de caractères
morphologiques qui fait que le clac des
afro saurai sida était déjà reconnu
avant qu'on ne
qu'on ne fasse des phylogénie
moléculaire on savait déjà que les temps
recchi et aube dorée était très
probablement reliés les uns aux autres
et se et ce dans un clac qu'on appelait
autrefois l'étant recco id voilà et
pourquoi parce que ils ont une
morphologie dentaire très particulière
les dents forment un seul vais donc
alors c'est une morphologie la langue de
dante mais avec un seul voeu voilà donc
je ne sais pas si on pourrait dire lampe
d'eau donc du coup je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir dire lampes de dont tu vu qu'il
ya qu un seul vow donc voilà les dents
en forme de v très caractéristique qu'on
retrouve que dans ce groupe là est la
fusion des deux zone naso donc le nasale
de gauche et nasale de droite sont
fusionnés chez ces deux chez ces deux
groupes des tenrécidés et les crises aux
coloris d après vous avez une réduction
du dosage ugal donc le gall est
complètement absent chez les temps rec
est en fait là vous avez une arcade
zygomatique chez les ch et les tops doré
donc vous pourriez être en train de vous
demander mais qu'est ce qu'il raconte il
ya un jus galles non il ya une arcade
zygomatique chez les crises au clos
rider mais le jus galles n'y participent
pas vous avez le square mozart qui
contacter directement le maxillaire et
rideaux il n'y a pas de ya pas de galles
en fait chez les ch et les crises au
chlore idées et aussi ce sont les seuls
mammifères qui ont un cloaque
donc ils ont un seul coup ils ont un
seul trou pour le pipi et le popo et la
semence
donc c'est intéressant parce que ça
c'est un caractère qu'on associe
beaucoup à la condition reptilienne
d'avoir un cloaque
et c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
une des principales raisons pour
laquelle les denrées coheed à l'époque
où on disait encore temps rico id était
considéré comme le groupe le plus banal
de mammifères probablement le groupe le
plus primitif de mammifères par beaucoup
de gens du moins pas par tout le monde
mais par beaucoup de gens
ça allait aussi de pair avec le fait que
le tenrec à l'un des plus petits et des
plus primitifs cerveau qu'on connaisse
chez les chez les mammifères donc le il
a un tout petit néocortex le néocortex
est très réduit chez l'échelle tant rec
et l'encéphale isation est vraiment
vraiment très très basse donc ça allait
de pair avec un aspect reptilien on va
dire donc les crises au chlore il est
avec raison que leurs idées ils sont
très particuliers donc comme je voulais
dit ce sont les tops doré et les taupes
dorée elle ressemble vraiment à fond à
des taupes donc encore une fois ça reste
assez difficile de digérer le fait que
ces taupes ne soit pas du tout apparenté
au top
voilà et on essaie on aimerait bien
comprendre d'où elles sortent en fait
c'est au doré le problème c'est que le
registre fossile ne nous dit rien ne
nous dit rien à ce propos parce que
voilà le crâne de namas cloris qui est
une taupe doré de l'éocène de namibie et
puis voilà que je vous pouvez aussi vous
pouvez jouer au jeu des 7 différences
faut être un spécialiste quoi pour
trouver les sept différents c'est cette
différence en fait les seules
différences sont dans la dentition n'y a
vraiment que dans la dentition que vous
pourrez voir mais sinon le crâne est
définitivement celui d'un chryso
chloride est moderne voilà et les crises
au chlore idées modernes ils ont plein
de dot apomorphine alors évidemment
comme je vous ai dit alors quatre jeux
galkina plus de galles il ya la
morphologie des doigts vous pouvez voir
que le doigt 1 2 et 3 sont extrêmement
développé et plat vous pouvez voir que
il n'ya pas deux eaux dans le bras vous
rappelez vous il ya un os de zoé plein
des saints dans le bras donc stylo pote
the go pod auto pod mais non pas chez
les top doré chez les top doré il ya un
tendon qui sait aussi fier donc le
tendon fléchisseur qui s'attache à votre
coude et à la manne et au poignet de
l'autre côté et bien il est aussi fier
chez les crises au chloride est donc il
ya en fait trois os dans le bras avant
donc tout ça c'est de l'adaptation
évidemment au mode de vie swiss heures
donc les crises au chlore idées sont
aussi intéressants parce que vous voyez
certaines espèces pas tout les plus
adaptés au mode de vie fruit soeurs
n'ont pas d'yeux et on ne retrouve que
dans le kalahari
donc c
dans le sud de l'afrique de manière
générale c c'est vraiment très très
spécial comme groupe les crises au
chloride est et puis bah a froissé ctive
aura avec un petit point d'interrogation
alors je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
qui avait un clac qu'on appelle un froid
à ses actifs il ya auquel on attache les
tumuli dans tes ces afro assez ctive
aura avec un point d'interrogation parce
que les tubes évidente et ils ont des
îles ont vraiment des trucs très
particulier en fait les déjà les
phylogénie moléculaire ont un peu de mal
à placer les tumuli dans tata donc les
oryctérope donc et c'est marre c'est
marrant en fait parce qu'il ya des
endroits où les phylogénie moléculaire
n'arrive pas encore à bien placer les
espèces et les oryctérope en font partie
quale les oreilles t rop il ya encore
des différences entre même entre les
phylogénie moléculaire les plus récentes
mais néanmoins il ya quand même le
consensus semble de se diriger vers le
placement des oryctérope comme groupe
frère d afro insectes ivorra mais du
coup il ya aussi des caractères
morphologiques qui rentrent en ligne de
compte
bon alors déjà on peut pas vraiment se
servir de la morphologie des dents chez
les au recteur up puisque comme tout bon
fourmilier qui se respecte ils ont perdu
la mort fait leur morphologie dentaire
est hyper hyper simplifiez vous pouvez
voir qu'il ya plus de n'y a plus
d'histoire depuis speed et tout ça il ya
même plus des mailles
donc c'est un peu comme les xena retr
d'ailleurs les autorités europe était
volontiers placer aux côtés des au côté
dé xena retr avant qu'on ne découvre les
affreux terre mais ce qui est
intéressant du coup c'est leur
morphologie dentaire qui est très
particulière puisque en fait les dents
sont faites de tubules de dentine donc
c'est pas de la dentine organisé
n'importe comment s'est organisé en
tubules et c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
ce groupe les tumuli dans tata donc les
dents en forme de tube bull mais
néanmoins même si la morphologie
dentaire peut pas vraiment être utilisé
à des fins de phylogénie on constate que
on a toujours une division sur les
molaires entre le talent honni des le
trigone id donc là
c'est à peu près le seul élément
d'ailleurs donc trigone ide et à l'onid
donc le seul élément de la morphologie
dentaire tribos pénique de base qui a
été retenu et ça ça ça semble pointer
vers un ancêtre herbivores une si grande
surface voyez de pour pour écraser la
nourriture ça semble pointer vers un
herbivore vers un ancêtre herbivores
d'autant que quand on regarde les
griffes de l'oryctérope eh bien on se
rend compte que ce ne sont pas des
griffes en réalité ce sont des sabots
les oryctérope n'ont pas de griffes ils
ont des sabots et ça c'est très si c'est
très important quand on sait que ils
sont ce sont des fonds milliers dont ils
ont besoin de leur grille il aurait bien
besoin de griffes pour défoncer les
fourmilières et les termitières mais non
ils ont des sabots et ça encore une fois
à avant qu'on ne connaît des phylogénie
moléculaire et les gens qui ne voulait
pas vraiment dire que les tumuli tenté
étaient de proches parents des xeneizes
il placé volontiers l'origine des tubes
billie dans tes parmi les condyles
artres et je serais pas surpris que dans
le futur on découvre on découvre des
entre guillemets condyle artres qui
ressemble à des oryctérope mais le
problème c'est que le registre fossile
des oryctérope ne permet pas du tout de
résoudre le problème quoi les plus vieux
oryctérope ils datent du milieu seine
inférieure ils ont déjà des têtes
dorique t rop
et après alors il ya aussi les histoires
de dispersion d'un vers madagascar qui
sont intéressantes à explorer avec les
temps et que les oryctérope c'est que si
on regarde une phylogénie en fait des
temps rec
enfin si on regarde que les espèces
modernes de temps règle donc celles qui
n'ont pas de petites croix comme celle
là on a une division en deux groupes d
potamot galinée qui sonde est en règle
semi aquatique qui vivent sur le
continent et on a les temps récit des
qui vivent tous à madagascar donc pareil
dispersion au cours du cénozoïque on
verra ça dans le détail quand on parlera
des primates
mais voilà on a un événement de
dispersion qui a eu lieu en fait à
madagascar
mais bon ben ça c'est pas un problème je
veux dire on a un groupe africain groupe
à madagascar un ancêtre commun qui a
donné toutes les espèces à madagascar
oui mais quand on regarde les espèces
fossiles
on constate que les espèces qu'on
retrouve sur le continent sont
apparentés aux espèces qu'on trouve à
madagascar
et ça ça devrait vouloir dire qu'en gros
il ya eu des allers retours entre les
deux et ça ça fout la merde ça fout la
merde et aussi dans l'histoire des
allers retours on appelait zurich
terreau opus donc qui est un oryctérope
qu'on retrouve à madagascar
sauf que lui enfin il est du quaternaire
de madagascar le problème c'est qu'on
n'a aucune idée d'où il vient ni de
comment il est arrivé là parce que en
fait il est disons qu'on en arrive à
dire que c'est un oryctérope certes aidé
mais au final la morphologie est
tellement différente de celle des
oryctérope que on se demande du coup
quand est ce qu'il est arrivé là et si
ça se trouve il est arrivé là il ya
peut-être 60 millions d'années et que
c'est pour ça qu'il est si différent
c'est parce qu'il est arrivé là il ya
tellement longtemps qu'il a beaucoup
changé par rapport à l'europe mais il y
a des phylogénie en fait commis date du
quaternaire on a réussi à extraire des
protéines du collagène et les séquences
de collagène ont été comparés aux afro
terre et il se trouve que plaisir
oryctérope en fait des séquences de
collagène qui serait plus cohérente avec
une origine parmi les temps récit des
temps en temps
donc voilà le truc qui s'appelle plaisir
ictère opus en référence à lorik tes
robes dont on pensait qu'il était le
descendant et ben en fait non si ça se
trouve c'est un temps rec qui est adapté
qui s'est adapté à un mode de vie
fourmilier et qui en tant qu'afro terre
a fini par ressembler à un oryctérope et
pan dans ta face donc la faire et non
conclut évidemment ça reste encore c'est
pas un débat enfin s'il n'ya même pas de
débat parce qu'il ya si peu de données
en fait on n'a que on n'a que très peu
on n'a pas tant de matériel que ça de
plaisir aux recteurs opus et comme j'ai
dit on à pas d'ancêtres potentiel pour
comparer donc peut-être si un jour on
découvre un ancêtre opposants potentiels
de plaisir et iter opus mais pour
l'instant bas le débat reste sur une
incertitude
voilà et puis une dernière chose à
propos de la distribution d'aidé aux
recteurs hop c'est que comme comme jeu
comme pour les irak aux ide en fait et
je l'avais rapidement mentionné sur
l'épisode sur les paiements gül et les
oryctérope au mieux scène vont connaître
un petit succès évolutif et se disperser
tout autour de pas tout autour du monde
mais au moins en eurasie au cours du
miocène et même au cours du pliocène il
n'est pas improbable d'ailleurs que donc
c'est un petit oryctérope de perpignan
dont je vous parlais en floride terreau
puce qui a été découvert dans l'est a
perpignan il n'est pas improbable que
cette oryctérope du pliocène et
traverser la méditerranée quant à elle
été complètement sèche il ya 5 millions
d'années bon après ces spéculations
évidemment on n'a pas ça assez difficile
de savoir quelles espèces ont
directement traverser la méditerranée
quand elle était sèche parce qu'il
faudrait vraiment avoir un registre
fossile à travers toute la méditerranée
pour le dire c'est possible il ya
certains rongeurs on sait qu'ils ont
traversé la méditerranée dans un sens et
dans l'autre il ya des rongeurs
européens qui se sont dispersés en
afrique mais mais voilà pour
l'oryctérope on ne saura pas c'est juste
que voilà à l'époque c'était le seul
oryctérope d'eurasie qu'on retrouve dans
le pliocène donc
il est peu probable qu'il soit venu de
16 ans il n'est pas il est peu probable
qu'ils soient venus d'asie puisqu'il n'y
avait pas deux fois qu'il est fait le
tour quoi vu qu'il y avait plus de
rester en europe en asie à cette époque
mais bon voilà c'est la petite histoire
d europe et donc pour conclure sur les
micromammifères et notamment sur les
micromammifères africain je voulais
juste vous montrer en fait les deux
groupes les deux grands groupes de
mammifères de mammifère insectivore donc
les oeufs l'ipo tiff là à gauche et les
afro affective aura à droite donc chez
les hollies poti flat vous avez le
hérisson et en à madagascar vous avez
les temps rec et là vous voyez la
ressemblance
en europe vous avez les taupes et puis
bah en afrique vous avez les taupes doré
voilà la ressemblance est aussi assez
flagrante et en europe en pardon aux
caraïbes
vous avez le sol et nos dons qui est
aussi un noeud l'ipo tiff là et en à
madagascar vous avez émis sans tête s
alors ils me sortent et s il ressemble
un peu à pokémon j'avoue mais si vous
regardez la tête
regardez comment commence à être tête
cette belle tête conique chez emi sans
tettey s'est regardé cette belle tête
conique
enfin non pas dans la belle tête
chroniques de solino dont et comparer là
la belle tête coniques de hémisynthèse
vous voyez quand même il ya il ya
quelque chose et puis quand on regarde
le crâne c'est encore pire donc hop si
je vous passe directement le crâne voilà
quand on regarde le crâne c'est encore
pire parce que le crâne des me sentais
de le crâne de solino dont vous pouvez
voir ici
il a des dents lampe d'eau dont tu es il
a pas d'art cas de gale et amy st eve me
sentais tu es sentant que tant est que
si des îles a des dents langnau dont tu
nous as langue de dante comme vous
voulez et il a pas d'art cas de gale
donc la convergence entre les deux est
quasiment parfaite elle est quasiment
parfaite la seule différence la
différence majeure c'est que sol et nos
dons est un mammifère venimeux et du
coup il a sept petites encoches sur la
canine inférieur qui permet d'injecter
le venin dans ses proies
c'est une des seules différences qui
entre les deux tous les deux ont un tout
petit cerveau la forme du crâne est très
très similaires
il ya vraiment très très peu de
différence entre les deux est ici si
vous comparez évidemment le crâne d'une
touba vous retrouver la même forme que
la craint que le crâne des taupes doré
les dents sont alors là pour le coup
elle sont à lambres deux d'entre eux et
ils disent même ce deal en dodon tu donc
ça permet de différencier le à se lever
des deux v1 donc là vous avez dit lampes
de dompter la vous avez à lambres dos
don'ts avec un se lever et donc c'est
mais vous avez quand même cette forme de
v qui est convergente et vous avez la
largeur du crâne on regardait le crâne
au lieu d'être et 3 comme celui de du
sol et nos dont le crâne est très large
au niveau de la boîte crânienne est ce
qui est aussi ce qu'on retrouve chez les
top doré donc tout ça ça a évolué
complètement de façon convergente c'est
de l'adaptation même milieu mais à deux
endroits différents et dans deux classes
complètement différent parce que les
afro insectivores a sondé à frotter ria
alors que les polypes au tiff là sont
dès lors asia teria donc voilà comment
on finit avec une histoire similaire
dans deux groupes complètement différent
donc voilà c'est la fin de ce court je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi et donc
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour le cours sur l'évolution des
primates
ça y est on attaque enfin le groupe
auquel nous appartenons
donc voilà à la semaine prochaine ciao